Moin, was gucken? Wisst ihr, was heute angesagt ist? Außerhalb von Twitch, ich meine nicht auf Twitch.
Auch nicht PvP-Event. Wisst ihr, was heute angesagt ist? Deswegen muss ich nämlich auch gerade was gucken.
Heute ist wieder sprichwörtlich passives Gelddrucken angesagt. Und zwar, wie gesagt, im übertragenen Sinne.
Weil ich habe wieder Wochenendbereitschaften, es ist bis jetzt noch nichts passiert und ich kriege fett Stonks pro Tag.
Soll mir recht sein. Also es kann sein, dass ich eventuell angerufen werde und den Stream ausmachen muss.
Aber es ist doch rechtfertigt.
Nicht unwahrscheinlich. Wahrscheinlich so gut wie nie war es am Wochenende.
Aber es muss erreichbar sein. Stunde Reaktionszeit.
Und dann muss man halt am Rechner sein in der Zeit und deswegen kriegt man halt auch ordentlich Kohle.
Kannst du ja alles machen, was du willst.
Ich könnte heute Morgen beispielsweise nicht hier mal in die umliegenden Berge fahren, eine Runde wandern gehen.
Das wäre vielleicht ein bisschen unglücklich.
Ein bisschen suboptimal.
Aber.
Ansonsten gibt es fett Money fürs Nichts machen.
Im übertragenen Sinne kommt es, glaube ich, noch am nächsten an Gelddrucken.
Einfach da irgendwo am Rechner sitzen und streamen, sondern Geld verdienen.
Pogge.
Da sind wir dabei, Leute. Da sind wir dabei.
Ich bin noch früher als sonst, habt ihr vielleicht festgestellt.
Wegen daran, weil ich noch nicht rennen war.
Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, ob ich rennen gehe heute.
Weil mir tut es beinahe noch ein bisschen weh von vor zwei Tagen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da ein bisschen übertrieben habe.
Da war ich mir nicht ganz normal.
Also weder sonderlich schnell noch sonderlich langsam.
Auch die ganz normale Runde, nichts besonderes.
Keine Ahnung.
Ein bisschen schepp gelaufen oder so.
Entweder gehe ich schon nach dem Mittagessen oder gar nicht.
Guck, dann morgen oder so.
Weil Mittwoch muss ich nach Frankfurt.
Und wenn ich in Frankfurt bin, dann auch gleich mexikanisch Mittagessen.
Gleich ordentlich.
Das muss man ja mit ein paar vorteilhaften Sachen.
Verbinden.
Ich weiß.
Wir haben in letzter Zeit wenig Bastlostreams gemacht.
Aber ich hatte einfach keine Brainkapazitäten übrig.
Nebenarbeiten.
Bisschen YouTube Zeug machen.
Kreiselgrind.
Und ab und zu mal streamen.
Dann noch Five Hat IQ Content auf Twitch.
Hab ich nicht hingekriegt.
Wir müssen demnächst die Cloud Docker Kubernetes Challenge Webseite da fertig machen.
Wir müssen auch noch Set Server.
Ein paar Sachen erledigen.
Also es gibt auch immer mehr.
Es gibt auch immer mehr solcher solcher Challenge Seiten.
Da geht uns theoretisch der Content nicht aus.
Aber ich muss erst mal geistig in der Lage sein dazu gerade.
Das Video geht noch ein paar Minuten.
Okay, zeig her.
Was ist das?
Linux Users Remove Plot.
Okay, lass mich mal prädikten, was in dem Video passiert.
Der Löt.
Wobei keine Ahnung.
Das ist es.
Das ist ein serieller Anschluss.
Dann von alles Notebook ausgebuddelt, wo es noch ein serieller Anschluss gibt.
Oder ist das USB auf Serial?
Weiß nicht, dass VGA.
Stimmt oder ist das?
Ich verwechsel das immer.
Ist VGA nicht 3 3 3 zeilig und das ist nur 2 zeilig.
Das müsste Serial sein.
Was sind sie bloß bloß ja ganz bestimmt heute Morgen.
So, wir gucken uns das jetzt mal 38 Sekunden.
Linux Users Removing Plotware hat das ist ein sehr realer Anschluss, aber weil VGA hätte 3 hätte 3 3 Zeilen quasi 3 3 Reihen Pins Postchamp.
Ach, jetzt check ich, was er macht.
Jetzt check ich, was er macht.
Der macht so ein kleines Mini Display dran und wahrscheinlich ist alles andere entfernt.
Und bloatet, wobei das muss VGA sein.
Das muss VGA sein, weil erstens Display.
Ohne irgendwie Microcontroller dazwischen.
Und zweitens hat das Ding ein HDMI Ausgang, also Notebooks zu Zeiten mit Display Port und HDMI Ausgang.
Die hatten keine seriellen Schnittstellen mehr normalerweise.
Was? Was?
Neo Fetch, bloat, bloatware removed.
Ja, das ist auch geil.
Dass er das, dass er das Notebook ohne Display hat, was ich mich frage ist oder was mir so gar nicht klar war, ist.
Dass man diese Displays tatsächlich.
An einen VGA Ausgang anschließen kann, dass sie das, dass sie das verstehen.
Oder.
Spricht er den VGA Ausgang irgendwie custom mäßig an mit irgendeinem, wie auch immer man das macht.
Mit einer Custom Software.
Also mir war das nicht klar, dass die das, dass die das unterstützen.
Ich dachte, diese Displays können halt nur dieses, dieses, tja, frag mich nicht, dieses andere Zeugs da.
Interessant, dass das überhaupt geht.
Aber bloatware removed, mehr braucht man nicht.
100 mal 50 Pixel oder was haben die Dinger denn immer?
Keine Ahnung, 160 mal 100 oder irgendwie so.
Muss, muss genug sein.
Aber immerhin, man erkennt, dass es Neo Fetch ist von der Ausgabe.
Schon mal nice.
Aber gerade.
Gerade beim Thema sind.
Ich habe das auch gelesen, dass das an den Pins steht.
Aber VGA braucht ja normalerweise ein bisschen mehr.
Das ist das ganz normale, dass diese ganz normale Pin Belegung.
Die man beispielsweise auch an irgendeinem ESP 32 verwendet mit x beliebigen.
Ja, deswegen wundert es mich.
Dann ist das nämlich doch, dann ist das nämlich doch ein serielle, serielle, aber es ist drei.
Es ist drei.
Reicht das Ding.
Da ist ein VGA Stecker.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie er das gemacht hat.
Vielleicht steht ja da was dran.
Ach, guck mal hier.
Ah, okay.
Interact with I2C on Linux.
Alles klar.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, dann aber über über den.
Aber über den VGA Port.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein VGA Port.
Okay, anscheinend, anscheinend erlaubt das Linux.
Anscheinend erlaubt das Linux, dass man den VGA Port.
Gut, ich meine.
Wusste zwar nicht, dass das so ohne weiteres möglich ist.
Die einzelnen Sachen, einzelnen Pins quasi von einem VGA Port anzusteuern.
Aber ist es anscheinend.
Das war mir auch nicht klar.
Oh, aber hab was gelernt.
Ist VGA auf jeden Fall.
So, wenn wir gerade dabei sind.
Ah, ja, ja, guck mal.
Command Line Weepshit.
Was ist?
Okay, Moment, One VPL.
Was habe ich da schon wieder installiert?
One, One VPL Runtime Implementation.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich das installiert habe.
Wahrscheinlich als irgendeine Dependency.
Äh, ich habe.
Absolut keine Ahnung.
Okay.
Ich mache mal Package Updates.
Einfach, weil ich das schon eine Weile nicht mehr gemacht habe.
Ich habe jetzt vor fünf, sechs Tagen zuletzt gestreamt.
Vor fünf Tagen, glaube ich.
Und nachdem unter 8 Linux natürlich übrigens hier mal mein Neo Fetch zum Vergleich
bisschen höher, mehr High Res als auf dem Mini Display.
Nachdem wir unter 8 Linux laufen, irgendwelche Package Updates kommen, vor allem.
QEMO ist gerade richtig dick dabei.
So wie es aussieht, sollten wir das mal machen bei Gelegenheit hier.
So, und wenn man Package Updates gemacht haben.
Dann brauchen wir noch Our Updates und dann.
Moin.
Und dann brauchen wir noch Jetbrain Dings IDE Kram Updates.
Wir haben Kernel Updates dabei.
Also Our Packages.
Machen wir die Jetbrains Toolbox auf.
Ich hoffe, dass das jetzt nicht mehr meine VM abfuckt wie das letzte Mal.
Ist er in den Kram hier Rastrover?
Brauche ich das überhaupt noch jemals wieder?
Ich aninstall es einfach.
Keck Wait, wenn wir immer wieder Rast machen, dann werde ich es einfach wieder installieren.
So, Massive Passwort kommt ihr nie drauf.
Update fertig.
Deswegen mag ich Archlinux.
Das ist immer so schnell geupdatet.
Manch einer würde sagen, das ist auch so schnell kaputt geupdatet.
Aber da muss ich dagegen halten.
Ich hatte noch nie Probleme mit Archlinux Updates, obwohl das potenziell natürlich
mehr unstable ist und und mehr Probleme verursachen könnte als jetzt beispielsweise
ein Debian Update.
Aber hattet ihr schon mal Probleme für alle Archlinux User by the way?
Also für das, dass das so aktuelle Software hat, ist das immer erstaunlich problemlos.
Muss dazu sagen, ich hatte zwar schon.
Ich hatte schon Probleme nach dem Update.
Vielleicht habe ich das falsch ausgedrückt.
Ich hatte aber noch nie Updates so nach dem Motto, dass das nicht mehr gebootet ist.
Probleme hatte ich nach Updates.
Minimal auch schon.
Beispielsweise hatte ich mal eine Kernel Version, die hat in der VM einfach extrem geleckt.
Könnt ihr euch vielleicht noch daran erinnern, wo du, wo du teilweise hier den.
Oder was geschrieben hast und der hat zwischendrin immer gestoppt, so wie ich jetzt hier von Hand
nachmache und dann erst weitergeschrieben.
Auch schon ein bisschen ein bisschen verbuckt.
Update durch.
Checken, ob AskIquarium noch funktioniert.
Allerwichtigste, nice funktioniert, geht exzellent.
So, GitHub, schauen wir mal, was diese Woche trendet.
Ich werde alles mit AI wieder skippen.
Du hast schon mal Arsch zerschossen durch Updates.
TS-Fox, danke für 20 Monate Massive Subscription.
Es gab doch vor nicht allzu langer Zeit.
Vielleicht erinnert sich da jemand dran.
Es gab doch vor nicht allzu langer Zeit ein Problem mit dem.
Mit Krupp, wenn man Krupp verwendet hat als Bootmanager, da gab es doch ein Problem bei Arschlinux.
Oder war das so ein Problem bei Manjaro damals?
Vielleicht membert der ein oder andere.
Das hat ja ein paar Installationen geschrottet, weil das irgendwie nicht bootbare Krupp Menü
Einträge oder irgendwie sowas im Kopf gar nicht mehr hin erzeugt hat.
Das hattest du, okay.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht mal, was das war, aber zumindest ich hatte es unter meiner vor allem nicht, weil ich verwende ja kein Krupp.
Ich verwende ja Chatgear.
Was verwende ich eigentlich?
Das ist das System Boot System Boot D ist das ist das System Boot D also nicht Krupp auf jeden Fall.
Das System System D Boot D oder wie das heißt oder System D Boot.
Ich glaube, das ist System D Boot.
Es gibt doch.
Es gibt doch so neuen Boot Manager, der in letzter Zeit recht beliebt ist.
Wie heißt denn das Ding nochmal?
Es gibt Krupp, es gibt System D Boot und.
Und dann gibt es noch was drittes, was in letzter Zeit so auf Reddit Reddit Unix Porn beliebt ist, wo die Leute immer erzählen, was sie verwenden.
Ich habe es nicht Lilo.
Lilo war vor 30 Jahren, okay, 20 Jahren beliebt.
Weiß gar nicht, gibt es das überhaupt noch?
Das war gut.
Lilo Bootloader Github wird das noch entwickelt?
Bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, ob das top aktuell ist.
Tatsächlich.
Vor sechs Jahren OpenSUSE Lilo ja null Sterne spricht für die Beliebtheit.
Denn du darf danke für den SAP und Panda POG Subscriptions Leute.
Hast du schon mal mit Webstorm gearbeitet?
Ja, das war ausingeniert.
Hat keiner mehr Bock, sich drum zu kümmern.
Es ist es ist X ist X11 auch aus X Org auch ausingeniert, weil dann auch keiner weiß, ob man, ob man X Org ingeniert nennen kann von dem, was man da so liest.
Ja, aber ich habe schon mal mit Webstorm gearbeitet.
Ja.
Geht mir genauso Battleship.
Guck mal.
Ich habe von Jet Brains Flameshot noch installiert.
Es funktioniert nicht.
Ich habe hier von Jet Brains.
Ach, guck mal, ich darf das Fenster wieder bewegen, ohne dass meine VM abkackt.
Ist ja auch sehr nett.
So, ich habe von Jet Brains dieses All Desktop Package und du hast ja eben gesehen, ich hatte eben noch die neue Rusty.
Ach, ist sie jetzt raus?
Ist sie nicht mehr Alpha?
Rust Rover ist jetzt offiziell.
Ist sie jetzt offiziell oder ist sie noch Alpha?
Nee, das ist noch Alpha.
Steht bloß nicht dran.
Also, was ich in letzter Zeit verwendet habe.
Von Jet Brains hier ist Rider für C-Sharp.
Das ist eigentlich das, was ich am meisten von denen verwende.
Ich finde, Rider hat wirklich, also bei mir wirklich richtig eingeschlagen.
Da brauche ich kein Windows mehr für .NET-Entwicklung.
Man hätte zwar theoretisch vorher auch schon kein Windows für .NET-Entwicklung gebraucht, solange es .NET Core gab oder gibt, beziehungsweise früher gab es ja noch Mono und Monodevelop.
Das ging auch irgendwie, aber schön war was anderes.
Aber Wischel.
Das Studio Code mit .NET ist halt, auch wenn die letztens, glaube ich, ein neues .NET-Plugin bekommen haben, nicht so geil.
Und Rider hat halt dazu geführt, dass ich .NET-Entwicklung nur noch unter Linux mache, seit Jahren schon.
Rider ist das Beste.
So, PyCharm, ab und zu ein bisschen Python-Zeug.
Warum ich die Professional-Version habe von PyCharm, kann ich euch auch erklären.
Das ist aus höchst seriösen Professional-Programming-Gründen.
Das ist, weil ich das Abo abgeschlossen habe und weil es geht.
Nicht, weil ich irgendwie...
Irgendwelche Features davon bräuchte.
So, Goland für Go.
Und dann hatte ich letztens noch Rust, Rust Rover am Start für Rust.
Ansonsten, was ich sonst noch davon verwendet habe, ist RubyMine, tatsächlich, früher.
In letzter Zeit nicht mehr, weil ich in letzter Zeit nichts mehr in Ruby mache.
IntelliJ.
IntelliJ musste ich letztens für irgendwas, ich habe es vergessen, Chat, wir haben das doch im Stream verwendet, für irgendein...
Ach, Kotlin.
Kotlin.
Wir haben ja ein bisschen Kotlin gebastelt, vor einem Dreivierteljahr.
Ja, oder so.
IntelliJ.
So.
Data-Crypt habe ich irgendwann mal installiert und gedacht, das ist viel zu overkill für mich.
C-Line habe ich tatsächlich schon das eine oder andere Mal verwendet.
Aber WebStorm.
WebStorm habe ich auch benutzt.
Und ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, Battlesheet, mir ging es da wie dir.
Ich bin ja, was Frontend-Sachen angeht, hauptsächlich, hauptsächlich, genau, auch an Visual Studio Code gewöhnt.
Und ich habe mir dann überlegt, okay, was für Vorteile hat jetzt WebStorm für mich?
Und ich habe auf den ersten Blick keine gesehen und deswegen verwende ich auch kein WebStorm.
Ich habe es auch nicht installiert, obwohl ich das All-Desktop-Package habe und den anderen Chatbrains-Krempel verwende.
So könnte man eigentlich sagen, ich verwende für alles Server-seitige halt Chatbrains, IDEs oder für irgendwelche Command-Line-Tools oder sonstige Sachen.
Ja, und für Frontend-Sachen Visual Studio Code.
Was ich auch noch Visual Studio Code verwende, ist Plattform IOM.
Micro-Controller-Krempel.
Das habe ich mal probiert in C-Line.
Das hat aber nicht so gut funktioniert.
Ging aber auch.
So, so sieht es aus.
Nutzt du Wayland als Desktop-Environment?
Pass mal auf.
Ich glaube, das beantwortet es.
Jetzt hat mein Desktop-Hintergrund keinen Bock mehr.
Ah ja, hier, da ist er.
Frühstücks-Pepo am Start.
Moin.
Bist du gespannt auf Fleet?
Ja, ich bin seit Beta oder Vorschau oder wie auch immer das hieß, gespannt auf Fleet.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass sich da so viel tun wird, weil es hat sich die letzten zwei Jahre nichts getan.
Und ich hätte zur Zeit echt keine Ahnung, für was ich Fleet überhaupt verwenden sollte.
Und diese, also, das nimmt ja nur Fahrt auf, wenn die Leute, auch wie du sagst, schon Plugins entwickeln können.
Visual Studio Code hat sich aus mehreren Gründen durchgesetzt.
Erstens, weil Microsoft das richtig gut supportet.
Weil es einer der wenigen JavaScript-Editoren ist, der zu dieser Zeit entstanden ist, den man benutzen kann, ohne einzuschlafen dabei,
beziehungsweise ohne, dass es rumruckelt und laggt und Input-Delay hat und alles mögliche.
Und, weil es JavaScript für Plugins hat und es Gott um die Welt an Plugins gibt für Visual Studio Code.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was witzig ist?
Das Einzige, was es nicht gibt, das ist eigentlich komplett...
Richtig, richtig...
Das Einzige, was es nicht richtig gescheit gibt, ist ein Browser-Plugin für Visual Studio Code.
Obwohl Visual Studio Code selber ein Browser ist.
Versteht das irgendjemand? Ich verstehe das nicht.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Irgendeinen Grund muss es ja haben.
Aber ist schon lustig, ne?
Dass es in einem Browser keinen Browser gibt.
Also, davon abgesehen, brauchen tue ich einen Browser-Plugin Visual Studio Code vom besten Willen nicht.
Ich meine, wozu?
Sollte ich einen Browser-Plugin brauchen?
Machen wir Visual Studio Code mal auf.
So.
Und wenn ich jetzt Frontend-Sachen machen will, dann starte ich einfach Chrome.
Und ob das jetzt ein Tab im Visual Studio ist oder ein Tab hier.
Also, ist jetzt nicht so, als macht es einen großen Unterschied, ja?
Max, darf ich dir mal eine Frage stellen?
Es ist eine Aufgabe aus der Schule.
Ja, auf geht's.
Okay.
Ich habe gesehen, es gibt Leute, die versuchen das auf ähnliche Art und Weise, einen Browser in Visual Studio Code zu bringen.
Und die streamen quasi eine Background-Chromium-Instanz da als Bilder irgendwie rein.
Ganz furchtbar weirder Kram.
Das ist natürlich performance-mäßig auch nicht so geil.
Und ich habe auch noch nicht so genau verstanden, warum.
Aber es gibt Visual Studio Code im Browser.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Was übrigens sehr nice ist, und die neuen GitLab-Versionen auch Visual Studio Code als Web.
Das heißt, man kann auch einen Web-Editor verwenden, äh, nicht GitHub, GitLab, hab ich GitHub, ach, keine Ahnung, GitLab, meine ich.
Das Weltplugin für WebStorm ist auch nicht so pralle, ja, mag sein, glaube ich dir sofort.
Auf, schieß los mit der Frage aus der Schule.
Wir gucken uns jetzt, bis die Frage aus der Schule hier ankommt.
Mann, je nachdem, wir machen jetzt nicht, wir machen jetzt nicht die Hausaufgaben, ja.
Wie benutzt man einen Schlüssel, um eine Verbindung abzusichern?
Ey, das könnte ja fast eine IHK-Frage sein, so kontextlos ist die.
Hahaha.
Die ist komplett, die ist komplett kontextlos, die Frage, Alter.
Wie benutzt man einen Schlüssel, um eine Verbindung abzusichern?
Nachdem sie von Verbindung sprechen, ver...
Ey, keine Ahnung, das, das, also ohne Kontext ist das nicht zu beantworten.
Aber was habt ihr denn in der Schule gemacht in letzter Zeit?
Ich mein, da kann man sich ja vielleicht draus, draus erschließen, aber ohne, ohne Kontext ist das, ist das nicht zu beantworten.
Man, man könnte vermuten, dass sie halt eine, nennen wir es mal...
Leihenhaft ausgedrückt, Netzwerkverbindung meinen.
Also sprich, irgendwas.
Im Browser zum Beispiel.
Also mein, Netzwerkverbindung ist ja, ist ja die, die genericste Bezeichnung ever, ja.
Und normalerweise verschlüsselst du ja auch gar nicht auf Verbindungsebene, sondern du verschlüsselst auf...
Tja.
Das ist schwierig zu sagen.
Auf welcher Ebene verschlüsselt TLS?
Das ist nicht wirklich Anwendung.
Das ist eigentlich schon eher auf...
Eins auf TCP drauf.
Also quasi...
Wenn man das nach dem OSI-Modell macht, dann auf Schicht...
Äh...
Vier?
Fragezeichen, Leute.
Ist das nicht vier?
Das ist schon so weile her.
Ne, Session ist glaube ich sechs.
Oder fünf?
Warte mal.
Okay.
Passt mal auf.
Nicht sagen, nicht sagen.
Ich will mal gucken.
Ich will mal gucken, ob ich die OSI-Modell-Layer zusammenkriege.
Also.
Please do not throw salami pizza away.
Irgendwie so ging das doch, gell?
Dieser Merksatz für OSI-Modell.
Also P.
Physical.
D.
Ich glaube auf Deutsch heißt das...
Bit-Übertragungsschicht.
Ich glaube das heißt sowas wie...
Ne, das ist Bit-Übertragungsschicht.
Ähm.
Warte mal.
Das ist...
Datalink.
Genau.
So.
Network.
Transport.
Session.
Application.
P fällt mir jetzt nicht ein.
Presentation.
Ah, ja, ja.
Genau.
Das ist das, was total vage ist.
Presentation.
Ja, genau.
Falsch?
Wieso ist das falsch?
Doch richtig.
Ich hab doch genau...
Ihr habt das doch gut aus dem Kopf hingekriegt.
Ist doch alles richtig.
Wobei.
Ich bin mir...
Ich bin mir da gar nicht so ganz sicher.
Ehrlich gesagt aus dem Kopf, wie das...
Auf welcher...
Auf welcher Ebene genau...
TLS ansetzt.
Also...
Es kann ja nicht TCP sein, weil TCP-Handshakes und sowas, das passiert ja alles.
Das müsste also eins oben drüber sein.
Also müsste das wahrscheinlich Schicht 5 sein.
Jetzt hab ich natürlich meins hier gelöscht.
Schicht 5 ist...
Session.
Ja.
Also auf Session-Ebene müsste...
Nee, müsste TLS sein.
TLS...
Ich kann mir das...
Ich kann mir das immer schlecht merken.
Also beim Verbindungsaufbau...
Warte mal, warum ist das so laut gerade?
Ist das gar nicht...
Also bei einem Verbindungsaufbau, zum Beispiel hier, wenn ich jetzt ein Web-Request mache zu Twitch.
Die Seite ist hier...
Ah, DTPS.
Ist es ja so, dass erstmal eine...
Also erstmal logischerweise DNS-Namensauflösung dahin.
Und dann...
Dann TCP-Handshake mit dem Server auf der anderen Seite.
So.
Dann wird...
Über diese bestehende TCP-Verbindung wird ein...
Wie heißt das?
Zumindest passiert das in 90% der Fälle heutzutage.
Wird ein...
Ein...
So eine Art Hostname mitgeschickt.
Das heißt nicht Hostname, das heißt irgendwie anders.
Zertifikatsname oder sowas.
Was ist denn da krampel?
Also so, dass du quasi...
Mehrere Sachen auf...
Also mehrere...
DLS-Sachen auf einer Kiste laufen.
SNI.
SNI, genau.
Das meine ich.
Ja.
Wird mitgeschickt.
Anhand dessen weiß der Server quasi...
Das ist so eine Art...
Das ist sowas wie Host in HTTP quasi.
Anhand dessen weiß der Server, wo du hin willst.
Und dann macht er da drauf halt seinen Verschlüsselungs...
Tja.
Key-Austausch erst mit...
Also...
Synchronem Verschlüsselungskram.
Synchronem Schlüsselaustausch.
Und dann Verbindung aufgebaut.
Und dann macht er sein HTTP-Request drüber.
Ja.
Server Name Indication.
Genau das meine ich.
Soweit ich das aus dem Kopf zusammenkriege.
So und jetzt auf die Frage zurück zu kommen.
Äh.
Wie benutzt man...
Wie benutzt man einen Schlüssel, um eine Verbindung abzusichern?
Es ist so vage und so kontextlos.
Das kann man an der Stelle echt nicht beantworten.
Also was heißt...
Was habt ihr denn in der Schule gemacht?
Das, was man da...
Nicht asynchron, asymmetrisch.
Ja, meine ich.
Es ist ja fast schon IHK-Level, die Frage.
Wie benutzt man einen Schlüssel, um eine Verbindung abzusichern?
Nein, die...
Ich meine, das kann ja von allem...
Das kann sein...
Wie hinterlege ich einen eigenen Key in Putty?
Zu...
Wie funktioniert das wirklich auf Netzwerkebene?
Das kann man...
Also...
Keine Ahnung.
Das kann man ohne Kontext nicht beantworten.
Aber ganz ohne Kontext wird die Frage ja nicht gestellt sein, oder?
Ja.
Du kannst den Serverraum damit abschließen, mit dem Schlüssel.
Visual Studio Code auf meinem Home-Server?
Du meinst den Browser?
Ja, kann man machen.
Ich meine...
Aber wenn ich irgendwas editieren will auf dem iPad,
dann würde ich irgendeinen Code-Editor, den Text-Editor auf dem iPad...
Ganz ehrlich, ich würde eh Anfälle bekommen,
auf dem iPad was programmieren zu müssen.
Okay, wir googeln das jetzt mal.
Wir machen das jetzt, was der Chat vorschlägt.
Ja, gut, die erklären was von Public und Private Key und sowas.
Thema ist Security, Begriff und Verschlüsselungsverfahren.
Ja, na gut.
Dann weiß man ja schon, in welche Richtung es ist.
Und dann hattet ihr sicherlich im Unterricht auch was,
wo man weiß, auf was sich die Frage bezieht.
So ganz...
Also ganz...
Selbst das ist super kontextlos.
Security, Begriff und Verschlüsselungsverfahren.
Ist das der deutsche Merksatz?
Anwendungsschicht?
Nee.
Sicherungsschicht?
Bindung?
Ich kann mir die Dinger nicht merken.
Und was ist Layer 8?
Du meinst den Twitch-Chat?
Ich hab den Eindruck, du hast nicht aufgepasst.
Drängt sich mir so auf.
Okay, weil man mit IPsec anfängt, hat man eh schon verloren.
Der Kontext ist das.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Wie erstellt man einen Schlüssel...
Aha!
Ja, da kommen wir doch der Sache schon deutlich näher.
Da kommen wir der Sache doch schon deutlich näher.
Okay, also...
Wie erstellt man ein Schlüsselpaar und oder eine OpenID?
Was OpenID ist, weiß ich nicht.
Klingt nach irgend so was wie OAuth oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Wie benutzt man einen Schlüssel, um eine E-Mail zu verschlüsseln?
Ah, ja.
Wie benutzt man einen Schlüssel, um eine E-Mail zu entschlüsseln?
Wie benutzt man einen Schlüssel, um eine Nachricht zu signieren?
Wie benutzt man einen Schlüssel, um eine Verbindung abzunehmen?
Wie benutzt man...
Ja.
Okay, hier ist der Kontext ja klar.
Ihr hattet wahrscheinlich im Unterricht OpenID.
Und der will das jetzt eher aus Anwendungssicht wissen.
Der will nicht, dass ihr erklärt, wie das funktioniert.
Sondern zumindest lese ich das so raus.
Der will wissen, wie man beispielsweise, nachdem man sich wie auch immer eine OpenID generiert hat.
Ich kenne OpenID nicht.
Und bei OpenID erhält man dann wahrscheinlich ein paar Keyfiles.
Wie man das...
Ja, in...
Pja, was auch immer.
Thunderbird oder wo auch immer hinterlegt, um das zu verschlüsseln.
Aber das hattet ihr ja wahrscheinlich, ne?
Also ich habe keine Ahnung, was OpenID ist.
Und wenn nicht, solltet ihr es vielleicht daheim rauskriegen.
Was ist denn OpenID?
Keine Ahnung.
Chatge, kennt irgendjemand...
Kennt irgendjemand Open...
Was ist das?
OpenID ist ein dezentrales Authentifizierungssystem für webbasierte Dienste.
Alter, das ist ja...
Also mehr generic kann die Einleitung jetzt ja auch nicht sein, oder?
Ist das...
Ist das irgendeine deutsche...
Äh...
Login-with-Google-Alternative, oder was?
Okay.
OpenID ist ein dezentrales Authentifizierungs...
SL...
Okay.
Ja, Singles, also irgend sowas wie OAuth oder sowas.
OpenID.net habe ich noch nie gehört, äh.
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Keine Ahnung.
Für die Anmeldung mit OpenID...
Es ist irgendein Authentifizierungs...
Provider...
Gedöns, ja.
Also im Prinzip ein bisschen sowas wie Login-with-Google, Login-with-Facebook...
Login-with-Github und sowas.
Irgendeine OAuth-Geschichte, hätte ich jetzt auch gedacht.
Ja, OAuth.
Ja.
Aber...
Also benutzt...
Keine Ahnung.
Habe ich das noch nicht.
Ich meine, der wird euch doch die Frage nicht einfach, ohne dass ihr was gemacht habt, so vor den Latz klatschen.
Ja, das muss ja doch schon ein bisschen drum gegangen sein.
Also das sieht aber eindeutig aus Anwendersicht aus, wie er das wissen will.
Also, oder wie seht ihr das Chat?
Also ich finde, in dem Kontext...
Da kommen die Fragen nicht danach, erklären sie, wie Private-Public-Key-TLS-Gedöns funktioniert oder Zertifikate, sondern hier wollen sie wissen, nachdem ich den OpenID-Assistent durchgeklickt habe, was auch immer, wie das aussieht, wie richte ich mein Thunderbird ein, um E-Mails zu verschlüsseln, wie richte ich mein Thunderbird ein, um E-Mails zu entschlüsseln, wie signiere ich damit Nachrichten...
Oder halt mit irgendeiner Software, die ihr im Unterricht hattet.
Keine Ahnung, was ihr da für ein E-Mail bringt.
Echt, was ist das für eine Schule?
Also was machst du da?
Würde mich auch mal interessieren, so den Kontext von...
Ist das noch quasi irgendwie Realschule, Abitur?
Ist das Berufsschule?
Ist das irgendwie...
Was gibt's da sonst noch?
Fachabi oder so, was ist das?
Ja, aber gut.
Ich meine, mit ein bisschen Nachgucken kann man die Frage schon beantworten.
Technikerschule, mit ein bisschen Nachgucken kann man die Frage schon beantworten.
Man müsste jetzt noch wissen, auf was sich das bezieht.
Wie benutzt man einen Schlüssel, um eine E-Mail zu signieren?
Dann würde ich mir einfach raussuchen, wie man es beispielsweise mit Thunderbird macht, ja?
So seht ihr Thunderbird, OpenID.
Ich meine, auf die Idee bist du wahrscheinlich selbst schon gekommen.
Und da liest ihr durch, wie der Cample funktioniert, ja?
Falls das geht.
Und dann klickt man wahrscheinlich...
Keine Ahnung, habe ich noch nicht gemacht, aber das klickt man schon mit ein bisschen Googeln raus.
Okay, ChatGP, wir wollten ChatGP, ChatGP, nicht ChatGP, wie komme ich da drauf?
Weil sich jemand geschrieben hat im Chat.
GitHub.
Wir wollten GitHub-Trends die Woche gucken.
Und ich werde wieder alles mit AI überspringen.
ChatGP, ja.
Die haben dann random Anzeigen auf dieser Map, wo das Auto gerade ist.
Die sind wahrscheinlich genauer als das echte Tracking von DPD.
Also es geht los mit CrewAI.
Also der Name hört sich schon so an.
Also immer.
Als ist AI und...
AI.
Alter, ist das Pfeifert, was?
Was?
Okay, Chat, 5 Punkte, wer checkt, um was es hier geht.
Mobile Aloha.
Learning by manual mobile manipulation with low cost whole body teleoperation.
Easy, oder?
Obviously.
Irgendeine Microcontroller-Geschichte?
Ich habe...
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, Mann.
Was das ist?
Chatbot-UI, okay.
Weg.
Facebook-AI-Zeug, um Gesichter zu erzeugen oder so.
Krempel, ja, genau.
Free and open source Manga-Reader for Android.
Ja, sind die...
Das ist die exzellente Weeb-App.
Java-Programmierübung.
AI, AI, AI, vermute ich mal.
AI, AI, nee.
Irgendwelches Security-Zeug.
AI, Android-Hackerman-Zeug, MAUI.
Warum trendet MAUI?
Ich warte jeden Tag auf den Blog-Post von Microsoft, dass MAUI eingestellt wird.
Irgendjemand von euch, der wirklich MAUI verwendet, der vielleicht im .NET-Umfeld ist, der wirklich MAUI verwendet?
Oder sagen wir mal so, der MAUI verwenden muss?
Okay, ich sage es noch präziser.
Irgendjemand von euch im .NET-Umfeld, der MAUI verwendet, schräg schräg verwenden muss und es mag?
Fragezeichen.
Ich habe das ja letzten schon mal gefragt und da hatten wir ein paar Leute, die noch Xamarin.Forms verwenden müssen und das auch schon kotzen.
Und MAUI ist ja quasi rebranded.
Okay, Blazingly Fast, written in Rust.
Das ist, die, die Rust, das Rust, das Rust-Projekt hier ist so high IQ, ich weiß noch nicht mal, was es bedeuten soll.
DataFrames powered by a multi-threaded vectorized query engine.
Alles klar, Leute.
DataFrames.
Polars.
Es muss wahrscheinlich Polar-AS sein.
Blazingly Fast DataFrames.
What?
Polars is a DataFrame interface on top of the OLAP-Query-Engine.
Ich weiß nicht, was das tut.
Ähm, Datenbank-Zeug?
Datenbank-Zeug?
Ich check's nicht, aber das ist zu high IQ für mich.
Unix-like kernel written in Rust.
Okay, ein weiteres Projekt der Kategorie Rust-Communication.
Community löst Probleme, die es nicht gibt.
Aber jeder, was er mit seiner, kann jeder mit seiner Zeit machen, was er will.
Äh, AI.
YouTube-Stells.
React, Frontend, Pocketbase.
Das ist keine Datenbank, oder?
Das kommt mir auch bekannt vor.
Das hab ich schon mal gesehen.
Pocketbase sagt mir irgendwas.
Ach, das ist die Geschichte.
Das ist quasi so ein bisschen Firebase-mäßig.
Nur im Kleinen.
Läuft das Archiv nicht damit? Max bist du da? Läuft das Archiv mit Pocket Base?
Das alte Archiv läuft mit irgendeinem Postgres im Hintergrund, dachte ich.
React vorne. Burn. AI. Okay, weg. Facechain. Deep Learning.
Okay, heute waren nur 80% AI. Nice. Mal ganz schnell, weil mich immer interessiert,
was trennt so in der C-Sharp Welt? Maui. Kotzen, Alter.
Power Toys, okay. Gut. Azure SDK, feilt nicht...
Pias oder PS... PS & G China. Chinense.
Collects scrap in VR... Was soll das sein? Ich habe keine Ahnung...
F-Mob... Braucht keiner... Counter Strike Sharp. Counter
Strike Sharp allows you to write server plugins in C-sharp for Counter strike 2.
Ja!
Counter Strike Sharp. Counter Strike Sharp. Allows you to write server plugins in C-sharp for Counterstrike 2.
weiß okay welche leute noch zuerst aber da gibt es dann gibt es demnächst dann auch propp hand
und so zeug in in cs2 weit gibt es wahrscheinlich schon nicht so spannend da machen wir die jungs
kiste mal wieder aus die probleme jetzt ja nicht und erst mal aufwachen avalon ja stream haben wir
schon ja ein bisschen mit avalon herum gebastelt mal irgendwann das schöne dass man das archiv am
start haben ob das archiv am start haben wo bloß archiv avalon ja immer so richtig schreiben
würde ja und sechs monaten okay das ist tatsächlich schon ein bisschen das war die jahre angeschaut ja
habe ich letztens alles mir aufgefallen es ist eine reine http also es kann nur http es kann
nur http es kann nur http es kann nur http es kann nur http es kann nur http es kann nur http es kann nur http es kann nur http
es kann nur
capita awaylikov ak75
in letzter zeit ja das wollte ich jetzt eigentlich sagen ja cats gab es die woche noch
irgendwas was ich irgendwie verdrängt habe dass das fritz boxen verboten
wurden haben wir ja auch enjoying das fritz boxen verboten wurden habe ich ein
video zugemacht was enorm gut angekommen ist guckt euch das waren es hat
innerhalb von einem tag fast 50.000 aufrufe bekommen weil die leute fritz
boxen mögen glaube ich das ist mein meist aufgeruf das video in langer zeit
innerhalb von einem tag nicht insgesamt auf aber innerhalb von einem tag ist es
habe ich in letzter zeit kein anderes video hochgeladen was so viel aufrufe
bekommen hat der titel ist glaube ich ganz nice ja
natürlich sind die leute teilweise wieder darauf angesprungen so nach dem
motto so ein scheiß clickbait titel wobei man sagen muss ich habe ja das
ziemlich genau wiedergegeben wie die aktuelle situation
ist und laut dem gerichtsurteil ist das das ende der fritz box wie wir sie
kennen die news seiten waren sich nicht darüber einig ob das jetzt schon alles
entforst wird oder nicht ja um alle fritz boxen geht es nichts geht nur um
halbwegs moderne fritz boxen mit wifi 6 und da witzigerweise auch nicht alle
komplett was ich ein bisschen weird finde ist dass ich habe das hier glaube
ich sogar verlinkt was ich ein bisschen weird finde ist
dass avm firmwares released hat mit der gleichen versionsnummer die man sieht
dass irgendwas mit felder genau guck hier änderung anpassung von signal dass
das ist das ist die änderung um dies da geht um dies da geht und wo es um die
patent streitigkeiten geht änderung anpassung von signalisierung des
feldern bei wifi 6 also spricht die version hier gibt es zweimal einmal mit
diesem update und einmal ohne diesem update das ist
natürlich ein bisschen ein bisschen doof weil man könnte man könnte jetzt
argumentieren versionsnummern sind eigentlich dafür da dass man sowas
unterscheiden kann du hättest eine videoidee dann schießt
los ich glaube nicht dass es der azubi vergessen hat ich glaube das ist absicht
und zwar vielleicht dass man entweder nicht richtig nachvollziehen kann also
gerade huawei nicht richtig nachvollziehen kann wäre das jetzt
verwenden wir nicht dass sie nicht sagen können retroaktiv hier wir bekommen von euch jetzt so und soviel geld
noch und auch dass die leute die schon geupdatet haben nicht einfach nur
updaten müssen noch mal neu um das gleiche zu bekommen nur mit einem feature
deaktiviert das bestimmt absicht wenn ich es auch ein bisschen weird finde
ehrlich gesagt habe noch eine das motor frage was spricht gegen das motorgeräte
vom verbrauchtmarkt zu holen eigentlich nichts das einzige was
vielleicht der theorie dagegen spricht ist wenn man davon ausgeht dass china
china chinesen elektronikgeräte vielleicht eh schon nicht unbedingt die beste bildqualität
haben und vielleicht nicht so lange halten dass man nicht irgendwie kaputten
geräte kauft so nach dem lotto die leute sagen ich habe keinen bock mehr weil das
nicht richtig richtig funktioniert und die verkaufen das und du kannst dich
richtig feststellen im vorfeld dass es kaputt ist also aber ansonsten nur
eigentlich nichts was du aber auch machen kannst ist es gibt der
hersteller mittlerweile die fertige das motor geflächte geräte anbieten
das finde ich ganz sinnvoll wenn man nichts mehr findet am besten ist immer
noch diese billig china chinesen steckdosenleiste von hammer die die ja
nicht selbst gebaut haben die gibt es ja von 1000 verschiedenen herstellern die
haben aber so eine olle firma version drauf bei hammer dass man die noch ota
flaschen kann darkzone dankeschön für den sub wie opensource für basis
infra geschichten dafür sorgt dass einem ein hersteller nicht massiv in die suppe
spucken kann du meinst du meinst so nach dem motto
man kauft sich jetzt was von oracle oder sap
und
die stellen fest bei einer lizenzprüfung dass du drei millionen lizenzgebühren nachzahlen musste oder so und da hast du keinen bock drauf
oder du hast ein produkt und die stellen den support ein oder sowas in der richtung dass sie das nicht nicht
sagen wir so einfach bei einem verbreiteten open source produkt passiert
die proud com vmware übernahme echt da habe ich überhaupt nichts von mitgekriegt was ist denn da
vmware stellt
Altes altes schwachsinn
nicht vmware stellt
proud com stellt vmware zeug ein oder wie ist das
ich habe damit überhaupt keine berührungspunkte deswegen weiß ich nicht was da so abgeht
wir benutzen natürlich auch auf der arbeit vmware produkte aber damit habe ich nichts zu tun was administrationstechnisch angeht
Wie automatisch wird bei größeren anwendungen eigentlich versioniert
Es kommt auf das team den workflow und die anwendung an
in der regel würde ich sagen so kommt also
was machen will
also komplett automatisches versionieren
kannst du machen aber für release version würde ich immer einen manuellen tag oder irgendwie sowas
Anstreben macht ja keinen sinn zu sagen das kommt etwas freitag um 8 uhr
kommentiert wird das letzte kommt etwas freitag 8 uhr kommentiert wird wird jetzt unsere nächste release version oder so das macht ja keinen sinn also
Also release version die müssen schon
manuell getaggt werden und
dementsprechend dann auch noch mal getestet werden und bevor sie release werden
was man machen kann was was oftmals ganz sinnvoll ist es tatsächlich irgendeine bildnummer
hinten dran oder wie auch immer man es machen will
einfach dass man selbst gucken kann okay was benutze ich denn genau
weil es kann ja durchaus sein dass derjenige der das testet nicht derjenige ist da sich den source code ausgesteckt hat
ausgecheckt hat genau weiß welche version das ist das dann startet also irgendeine bildnummer
oder irgendein bild hash oder was auch immer
dass man sich anzeigen lassen kann bei den leuten die das testen dass du genau nachvollziehen kannst welches ist das ist das automatisch ist sinnvoll
aber ansonsten weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau was worauf was was du wissen willst
musste mal ein tool bauen das geht kommen jetzt checken versions nummern taggt also mit konventionen kommentiert naja gut
das kann man ja schon
als policy rausgeben so nach dem motto wir wollen wir wollen gescheite geht kommen mit messages
ich bin ja ich bin da ein bisschen zwiegespalten
es zu sehr zu übertreiben mit anforderungen an
vermeintliche code qualität
ich erzähle euch mal ein beispiel ich erzähle ich erzähle euch mal ein beispiel also bei uns auf der arbeit ist es so
dass wenn du was an der infrastruktur ändern willst in der cloud
das ist das meistens über terraform aufgebaut
und
du hast entweder mit deinem admin account rechte das zu machen
wobei du dann mit terraform probleme hast von einem notebook mit admin account und das funktioniert nicht gescheit
die einzige möglichkeit gescheit terraform sachen bei uns auf der arbeit zu deployen ist über eine
CICD pipeline
und damit du dort terraform sachen ausführen kannst
brauchst du so viele
nervige schritte
die einfach nur abfuck sind und dafür sorgen dass du so extrem langsam bist bei allem das fängt das fängt schon daran an
so damit du damit du was pushen kannst sagen wir mal sagen wir mal was ganz simples sagen wir ich soll für die
entwicklungsumgebung von projekt xy eine
vm aufbauen die irgendwas macht vm funktion ist egal
da ist das normalerweise mit terraform relativ einfach du nimmst den provider dass die also den den den das
Modul von dem jeweiligen cloud provider stellst ein ich will nur vorstellen mit dem jahren
32 gigabyte haben soviel cpu sprach zack netzwerk hätten
Niederen
So jetzt das ding
bei uns ist das so geregelt man kann das man kann das witzigerweise umgehen größtenteils deswegen
Ja egal auch gleich zu
zumindest
Jetzt musste erst mal ein modul bauen
Für für diese für diese geschichte dann brauchst du ein eigenes
in kitlab quez
projekt für die jeweilige für das jeweilige projekt und für die jeweilige umgebung da
musst du dort an terraform anlegen das inkluden von einem modul für die vm so und an jeder steck
an jeder stelle hast du die bescheuerten linting und checker also dass in irgendeiner pipeline
gecheckt wird dass das welt terraform ist da habe ich ja nichts dagegen das macht ja durchaus sinn
das zu checken aber die checken alles da sind checker mittlerweile drin ich habe letzten
terraform modul gebaut das hatte drei zeilen das hatte drei zeilen bash skript drin oder ist irgendein
linter für meinen bash skript losgelaufen und hat dann gesagt nicht mal so dinge wie lehrzeichen
hinter pipes sondern dass ich irgendwas vollkommen welt mäßiges nicht verwenden darf zum beispiel ich
hatte ich hatte in irgendeinem bester hatte ich so was hier drin
da hatte ich sowas hier drin sind sinngemäß hier echt hallo was ist mit meiner cellos
da hat ich sinngemäß sowas drin weil ried irgendwie sowas hier in der richtung hatte ich
da irgendwie sowas in der richtung und das hier hat er angemeckert so nach dem motto weil ried darf nicht verwendet werden weil ried darf nicht verwendet werden
warum darf weil ried nicht verwendet werden man weiß es nicht weil irgendein komischer linter der
meinung ist weil ried ist kein guter bash code und das ist so abfuckt mittlerweile auch meine
terraform module funktionieren teilweise aus den den wildesten gründen nicht weil es meint es erkennt
irgendein kommentarzeichen an den ich hatte letztens also in terraform machst du kommentare
so und nicht so es geht aber beides ist beides welle terraform so und ich hatte letztens irgendwo
irgendwie sowas drin stehen blub blub blub blub blub und da hat er gesagt kommentare sollen
gefälligst mit mit raus gemacht werden das ist so ist so dämlich also das ist so übertrieben teilweise
und da muss ich halt sagen dadurch wird die code qualität auch nicht besser es wird sich einfach
nur irgendwas gesucht um das ganze zu umgehen so und was jetzt teilweise die leute machen ist die
pushen einfach gar nicht mehr über
also die machen kein feature branch mehr und pushen dann den feature branch und machen
eine merge request und lassen die pipeline laufen sondern die pushen einfach blind in master weil
es dort die checks nicht gibt also das ist halt das ding wenn du es zu sehr übertreiben ist mit
automatisierten gängelungen dann suchen sich die leute irgendwie den weg drumherum das ist das
gleiche das ist das gleiche wie wenn du sagst passwortrichtlinien wenn du sagst passwortrichtlinien
mindestens
zeichen sonderzeichen anders nur nummern groß kleinschreibung und sowas theoretisch könnte
man das alles schön machen ja ist es halt nicht so und wenn du so übertriebene passwortrichtlinien
hast dann kommt dann sowas raus 123 abc anders score abc 123 und sowas so ach so ja vielleicht
vielleicht noch vielleicht noch irgendwie nebenbei sonderzeichen moment sowas sowas kommt dann raus
sowas hier guck das ist wenn du zu viele passwortrichtlinien hast da kommt dann sowas raus
123 123 abc anders score abc 123 123 das ist ein passwort
was allen sicherheitsrichtlinien genügt aber trotzdem ist und sicherlich in irgendwelchen
passwortdatenbanken schon drinnen steht deswegen also ich halte von zu komplexen
passwortrichtlinien gar nichts ja ja genau das ist unter anderem eines der probleme also ich
halte von so zu komplizierten passwortrichtlinien gar nichts die einzige passwortrichtlinien die ich
echt für sinnig halte ist einmal wenn du sicherstellen willst das passwort der
rotiert werden dass du sagst ey nicht exakt das gleiche passwort noch mal okay
logisch und eine länge eine länge finde ich sinnvoll dass man sagt mindestens
sagen wir mal 20 zeichen oder mindestens man könnte sogar sagen 24 zeichen oder
was auch immer aber dann sonst nix weil die länge ist ja letztendlich das
entscheidende bei einem passwort da können leute immer noch 24 stellige
dumme passwörter nehmen aber unterm strich glaube ich es gibt weniger stress
und und weniger kack passwörter und und mehr usability wenn man einfach nur eine
länge vorgibt weil wenn man wenn man einfach nur eine passwort länge länge
vorgibt ja notiz natürlich die leute schreiben sich schreiben sich das dann
auf also zum beispiel zum beispiel was was ganz gutes ganz gutes passwort wäre
wenn du sagst ey mindestens vier
wenn du sagst ey mindestens vier und 20 stelle dann würde ich sagen hier der
kann sogar groß beim der twitch chat ist heute 5 hat so das wäre ein ziemlich
gutes passwort es hat 1 2 3 4 5 ich habe mich verzählen wie 30 zeichen
oder sowas bei passwörtern auf jeden fall bei anderen sachen vielleicht auch
aber passwörtern kommt es mathematisch bewiesen auf die länge an
aber passwörtern kommt es mathematisch bewiesen auf die länge an hauptsächlich auf die länge das wäre ein
hauptsächlich auf die länge an hauptsächlich auf die länge das wäre ein
hauptsächlich auf die länge das wäre ein ziemlich gutes passwort ist natürlich
ziemlich gutes passwort ist natürlich
ziemlich gutes passwort ist natürlich blöd wenn ihr jetzt auf die idee kommt
blöd wenn ihr jetzt auf die idee kommt
blöd wenn ihr jetzt auf die idee kommt und das verwendet und dann sagt ja moment
und das verwendet und dann sagt ja moment
und das verwendet und dann sagt ja moment warum der max hat auch gesagt das ist
warum der max hat auch gesagt das ist
warum der max hat auch gesagt das ist ein gutes passwort also passwörter die
ein gutes passwort also passwörter die
ein gutes passwort also passwörter die irgendwo schon mal im klartext standen
irgendwo schon mal im klartext standen
irgendwo schon mal im klartext standen passwort darf nicht eines letzten 32
passwort darf nicht eines letzten 32
passwort darf nicht eines letzten 32 passwörter sein alter jetzt wollen sie es
passwörter sein alter jetzt wollen sie es
passwörter sein alter jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen wann 32 passwörter haben
aber wissen wann 32 passwörter haben
aber wissen wann 32 passwörter haben das aber echt also wir haben auf der
das aber echt also wir haben auf der
das aber echt also wir haben auf der arbeit auch bisschen übertriebene
arbeit auch bisschen übertriebene
arbeit auch bisschen übertriebene passwortregeln und ich habe mich noch
passwortregeln und ich habe mich noch
passwortregeln und ich habe mich noch nicht auf ein system festgelegt ob ich
nicht auf ein system festgelegt ob ich
nicht auf ein system festgelegt ob ich was hoch zähle und sonst was aber
was hoch zähle und sonst was aber
was hoch zähle und sonst was aber wahrscheinlich wird es darauf raus
wahrscheinlich wird es darauf raus
wahrscheinlich wird es darauf raus laufen ja so dann lasst uns doch mal auf
laufen ja so dann lasst uns doch mal auf
laufen ja so dann lasst uns doch mal auf youtube gucken was wir hier schon das
youtube gucken was wir hier schon das
youtube gucken was wir hier schon das haben übrigens ich muss heute abend
haben übrigens ich muss heute abend
haben übrigens ich muss heute abend wahrscheinlich ein bisschen ich muss
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen ich muss
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen ich muss muss ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen
muss ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen
muss ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen übertrieben ich werde abend
übertrieben ich werde abend
übertrieben ich werde abend vielleicht noch ein bisschen dark stream
vielleicht noch ein bisschen dark stream
vielleicht noch ein bisschen dark stream weil er gibt gerade pvp event und ich
weil er gibt gerade pvp event und ich
weil er gibt gerade pvp event und ich werde mit den ganzen tag spielen
werde mit den ganzen tag spielen
werde mit den ganzen tag spielen hallo hallo muss auch kurz gucken wie es
hallo hallo muss auch kurz gucken wie es
hallo hallo muss auch kurz gucken wie es steht da kurz gucken wie steht es denn
steht da kurz gucken wie steht es denn
steht da kurz gucken wie steht es denn aktuell die muss eingeloggt sein ja und
aktuell die muss eingeloggt sein ja und
aktuell die muss eingeloggt sein ja und easy easy ich bin noch im firefox hier
easy easy ich bin noch im firefox hier
easy easy ich bin noch im firefox hier eingeloggt sekunde sekunde und firefox
eingeloggt sekunde und firefox
eingeloggt sekunde und firefox ja wie steht es dann aktuell gerade
ja wie steht es dann aktuell gerade
ja wie steht es dann aktuell gerade oh oh wir sind nur noch sechs punkte 600
oh oh wir sind nur noch sechs punkte 600
oh oh wir sind nur noch sechs punkte 600 punkte hinten dran da werden wir
punkte hinten dran da werden wir
punkte hinten dran da werden wir vielleicht doch nicht letzter da muss
vielleicht doch nicht letzter da muss
vielleicht doch nicht letzter da muss ich da muss ich nach dem stream gleich
ich da muss ich nach dem stream gleich
ich da muss ich nach dem stream gleich wieder pvp kranken ist das hier live
wieder pvp kranken ist das hier live
wieder pvp kranken ist das hier live nein das ist recorded stream was ist das
nein das ist recorded stream was ist das
nein das ist recorded stream was ist das 3 an ich bin so viel ist gut was kann
3 an ich bin so viel ist gut was kann
3 an ich bin so viel ist gut was kann man sagen gucken was erfolgreiche
man sagen gucken was erfolgreiche
man sagen gucken was erfolgreiche programmierer tun und du wahrscheinlich
programmierer tun und du wahrscheinlich
programmierer tun und du wahrscheinlich nicht kompromant antivirus tier ist
nicht kompromant antivirus tier ist
nicht kompromant antivirus tier ist online please please das wird was da
online please please das wird was da
online please please das wird was da muss ich bleiben wenn ich das gucke
muss ich bleiben wenn ich das gucke
muss ich bleiben wenn ich das gucke wobei ganz ehrlich ich habe mir
wobei ganz ehrlich ich habe mir
wobei ganz ehrlich ich habe mir letztes jahr schon mal ein tier ist
letztes jahr schon mal ein tier ist
letztes jahr schon mal ein tier ist video von dem kerl angeguckt und ich
video von dem kerl angeguckt und ich
video von dem kerl angeguckt und ich muss sagen ich bin erstaunlich d'accord
muss sagen ich bin erstaunlich d'accord
muss sagen ich bin erstaunlich d'accord gegangen wie man so schön sagt mit
gegangen wie man so schön sagt mit
gegangen wie man so schön sagt mit seiner tier ist das war eine tier ist zu
seiner tier ist das war eine tier ist zu
seiner tier ist das war eine tier ist zu ich glaube linux wie wir haben zwei
ich glaube linux wie wir haben zwei
ich glaube linux wie wir haben zwei sachen angeguckt linux desktop
sachen angeguckt linux desktop
sachen angeguckt linux desktop environments und linux des und linux
environments und linux des und linux distros und ich konnte ich konnte seine
distros und ich konnte ich konnte seine
distros und ich konnte ich konnte seine sache zumindest nachvollziehen oftmals
sache zumindest nachvollziehen oftmals
sache zumindest nachvollziehen oftmals und gerade bei distros waren wir uns
und gerade bei distros waren wir uns
und gerade bei distros waren wir uns erstaunlich einig ja nur eine sache hat
erstaunlich einig ja nur eine sache hat
erstaunlich einig ja nur eine sache hat da drin stehen die verfahren ich total
da drin stehen die verfahren ich total
da drin stehen die verfahren ich total bescheuert aber gut das ist alles bis
bescheuert aber gut das ist alles bis
bescheuert aber gut das ist alles bis an sich sagen aber die antivirus tier
an sich sagen aber die antivirus tier
an sich sagen aber die antivirus tier lässt okay das video ist und zehn
lässt okay das video ist und zehn
lässt okay das video ist und zehn minuten lang das kann man schnell
minuten lang das kann man schnell
minuten lang das kann man schnell angucken wobei ihr wisst wenn ich zehn
angucken wobei ihr wisst wenn ich zehn
angucken wobei ihr wisst wenn ich zehn minuten videos gucken da ist gleich 13
minuten videos gucken da ist gleich 13
minuten videos gucken da ist gleich 13 uhr ich könnte ein bisschen was
uhr ich könnte ein bisschen was
uhr ich könnte ein bisschen was geben also im prinzip realistisch
geben also im prinzip realistisch
geben also im prinzip realistisch betrachtet die einzige antivirus sache
betrachtet die einzige antivirus sache
betrachtet die einzige antivirus sache die man aktuell verwenden sollte
die man aktuell verwenden sollte
die man aktuell verwenden sollte sprich kann es natürlich jeder machen
sprich kann es natürlich jeder machen
sprich kann es natürlich jeder machen wie er will ist windows defender oder wie
wie er will ist windows defender oder wie
wie er will ist windows defender oder wie heißt das ding jetzt eigentlich korrekt
heißt das ding jetzt eigentlich korrekt
heißt das ding jetzt eigentlich korrekt microsoft advanced protection oder so
microsoft advanced protection oder so
microsoft advanced protection oder so windows defender kommt mit windows mit
windows defender kommt mit windows mit
windows defender kommt mit windows mit fängt so die größten sachen ab und
fängt so die größten sachen ab und
fängt so die größten sachen ab und packt dein system nicht so das ist
packt dein system nicht so das ist
packt dein system nicht so das ist eigentlich ganz okay das habe sogar ich
eigentlich ganz okay das habe sogar ich
eigentlich ganz okay das habe sogar ich aktiviert aber selbst das nummer nummer
aktiviert aber selbst das nummer nummer
aktiviert aber selbst das nummer nummer so bevor man das wieder sagen selbst das
so bevor man das wieder sagen selbst das
so bevor man das wieder sagen selbst das ist nicht ganz ohne weil auch der
ist nicht ganz ohne weil auch der
ist nicht ganz ohne weil auch der windows defender hatte schon
windows defender hatte schon
windows defender hatte schon sicherheitslücken die das system
sicherheitslücken die das system
sicherheitslücken die das system angreifbarer gemacht hätte haben nicht
angreifbarer gemacht hätte haben nicht
angreifbarer gemacht hätte haben nicht hätten haben nachweislich angreifbar
hätten haben nachweislich angreifbar
hätten haben nachweislich angreifbar gibt's nämlich probleme nachweislich
gibt's nämlich probleme nachweislich
gibt's nämlich probleme nachweislich angreifbarer gemacht haben als ohne
angreifbarer gemacht haben als ohne
angreifbarer gemacht haben als ohne virenscanner das ist auch so ein ding
virenscanner das ist auch so ein ding
virenscanner das ist auch so ein ding was man immer bei der ganzen bei dem
was man immer bei der ganzen bei dem
was man immer bei der ganzen bei dem ganzen security software waren vergisst
ganzen security software waren vergisst
ganzen security software waren vergisst dem da viele verfallen gerade früher
dem da viele verfallen gerade früher
dem da viele verfallen gerade früher heute noch einige unternehmen jede
heute noch einige unternehmen jede
heute noch einige unternehmen jede software die man hat sorgt potenziell
software die man hat sorgt potenziell
software die man hat sorgt potenziell für probleme und sorgt potenziell auch
für probleme und sorgt potenziell auch für weitere sicherheitsprobleme also
für weitere sicherheitsprobleme also
für weitere sicherheitsprobleme also nicht nur für usability anwendungs
nicht nur für usability anwendungs
nicht nur für usability anwendungs abwagge sachen sondern auch für
abwagge sachen sondern auch für
abwagge sachen sondern auch für sicherheitsprobleme also alles was da
sicherheitsprobleme also alles was da
sicherheitsprobleme also alles was da ist kein probleme machen deswegen ist
ist kein probleme machen deswegen ist
ist kein probleme machen deswegen ist ja auch das beste auf einem linux
ja auch das beste auf einem linux
ja auch das beste auf einem linux server wenn man einfach nur die ports
server wenn man einfach nur die ports
server wenn man einfach nur die ports offen hat mit diensten die man auch
offen hat mit diensten die man auch
exposen will, dann brauchst du keine
Firewall, da brauchst du keine Regeln.
Dass das nicht immer geht, ist mir auch klar.
Aber wenn man die Ports,
wenn man nur die Ports offen hat,
am Public Interface,
die man auch
exposen will, dann brauchst du
so gut wie keine irgendwie die großartig
Netzwerktechnik, großartige Gedanken
zu machen. Es sei denn, die Anwendung,
die dahinter läuft, ist selber nicht
sicher genug, dass man sie ins Internet hängen
will,
weil man der Sache nicht traut.
Da muss man auch irgendeine Reverse-Proxy davor machen,
mit Authentifizierung oder sowas.
prinzipiell ist,
was nicht da ist,
oder nicht offen ist, oder nicht
vorhanden ist, kann auch keine Probleme machen.
Ist bei Datenschutz ähnlich,
oder bei Passwörtern in der
Cloud. Wenn eure Passwörter erst gar
nicht in der Cloud sind, bei irgendeinem Anbieter,
dann können die auch nicht geleakt werden.
Wenn ihr euch überall nur mit
Fake-Daten anmeldet, dann müsst ihr
nicht morgen damit
rechnen, dass eure
persönlichen Daten irgendwo
in irgendeinem Leak drinnen auftauchen.
Alles, was nicht da ist, kann keine Probleme machen.
So, dann gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an.
Tü-dü-dü-dü.
Antivirus-Tierlist.
Also aus meiner Sicht gibt es,
also für Windows, weil für andere Systeme
ist das eh meistens nicht sonderlich sinnvoll,
aber für Windows ist S-Tier
Windows Defender, ich würde noch nicht mal
sagen S-Tier, selbst Windows Defender
ist nicht unhinterfragt
immer geilst, überhaupt bestens.
Und für alles und das,
was man immer ungefragt machen
sollte. Ich würde sagen, es gibt
kein S-Tier-Antivirus, es gibt A-Tier-Antivirus.
Das ist
der Windows Defender und der Rest kommt in,
ja, was auch immer, D-Tier nicht benutzen.
Let's go over the best antivirus.
You see these all over, let's
make an actual tier list. Gibt es eigentlich schon
ein NordVPN-Antivirus mittlerweile?
Du musst werben, danke schön für den Sub.
I'm gonna do this a little different, because most
security channels obsess
over, hey, detection rates and
this percentage and a lot of marketing
...
Reden wir jetzt von Windows Desktop
oder was anderem? Also,
es gibt ja durchaus
legit Anwendungsfälle
für Virenscanner, so ist
das nicht. Zum Beispiel ein
Corporate File Share
oder sowas, also irgendein
Enterprise Business File Share
auf der Arbeit. Das muss
auch nicht mal ein Windows File Share
sein. Das kann auch eine Linux mit einem
Samba drauf sein, wo die Leute Dateien drauf
schieben können. Da ab und zu mal
einen Virenscan laufen zu lassen, ist durchaus sinnvoll.
Ich sag nicht, dass Virenscanner
allgemein komplett useless sind.
Gibt es
eigentlich noch
Moment, Sekunde.
Gibt es eigentlich noch Clam-AV oder
wie das heißt? Das war mal so ein
Open Source kostenloser
Virenscanner für Linux.
AV.
Der nie super
krasse Detection Rates hatte.
Ach, das gehört jetzt zu Cisco.
Oder zu Cisco, wie
das manche Leute aussprechen.
Moment, ist das jetzt written in Rust?
Ach ne, es hat nur Rust Bindings.
Das hat nur Rust Bindings.
Ich hätte schon gedacht. Moment.
Ja, das
hat nur Rust Bindings.
Okay, dann schauen wir mal.
Es kann da natürlich ein bisschen was skippen.
Es kann das, das, oder?
Manche Viren sind hier.
waitt
Füren.
Es gehen, wie Avira.
Wir gehen skilled.
Auf dem Maul coronavirus.
Was heißt Awwir auf?
Das gab es schon ziemlich gut,
nachdem dass lookout species
inventions feminin
Ne którym rechtlich richtig.
Ich hab früher auch immer
Avira verwendet.
Also das letzte Mal
so vor 15 Jahren oder so.
Es ist noch nicht ausgestattet.
Aber mit Windows Defender
wäre es in der classischenMSG.
Ich würde sagen, das ist.
Wenn so, dann wäre es PS Oak Imprif.
Ey, wenn der am Ende das genauso macht, wie ich vorgeschlagen hab, nur Windows Defender ist ATS, Tier ist nichts und der Rest ist, dann fände ich das sehr Poggers.
Hab ich nie verwendet. Hat das jemand mal benutzt?
Ich kenne die Logos gar nicht mehr. Ist das Bitdefender hier unten, Leute? Ist das Bitdefender das Einzige, was mir einfällt?
Ich kenne die... Okay, das ist Norton gewesen, oder? Ich kenne den Rest nicht mehr. Da sieht man mal, wie unbedeutend Virenscanner geworden sind, dass ich die Logos gar nicht mehr kenne.
Das ist Kaspersky. Das ist tatsächlich ein Fall, wo es sinnvoll ist, einen Antivirus-Anbieter zu haben.
Mir ging es ja hauptsächlich um Windows-Desktop-Systeme. So private Windows-Desktop-Systeme.
F-Secure als erstes. Das da hinten sieht aus wie wirklich irgendwie NordVPN oder so. Egal, schauen wir weiter.
Ich denke, ein großer Konglomerat hat beide jetzt. Und sie haben so viele Sicherheitsverletzungen.
Wo ist denn eigentlich McAfee hin? Gibt's das noch?
Eine große Angelegenheit, wenn man diese Free-Any-Virus-Systeme installiert. Also es gibt Pop-Ups überall. Und ehrlich gesagt, ihre Detektionsrate sind wirklich nicht anders als Windows Defender.
Also warum?
Warum? Sagen Sie mich auch.
Ich sehe keinen Punkt in either one of these. So, that's kind of it.
Now, to touch on the worst antiviruses in this list, which I'd say, hey, you're better off actually getting infected with a virus than having these installed, because I treat them worse than a virus.
I think we have to put in McAfee and Norton.
You might be thinking, wait a second, Titus, McAfee and Norton, they're like some of the oldest names in the entire market. They're on all these new computers.
Norton hat ja auch eine wilde, ja, wie soll man sagen, so Geschichte, wem's gehört. Das gehörte ja gefühlt auch schon irgendwie acht verschiedenen Eigentümern. Wem gehörten das eigentlich gerade?
Wem gehörten das eigentlich aktuell? Es war mal Symantec oder so zwischenzeitlich. Und was ist es jetzt? Wem gehört das jetzt? Wem gehört das jetzt?
Trend Micro.
Nee, Symantec, ist es immer noch? Ach, Gen Digital heißen die jetzt.
Gen Digital, das ist so weird, also das hat auch schon zig Dinger durchgemacht.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, ja. An diesen Krempel kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Erinnert sich noch jemand an Norton Internet Security Suite?
Kennt das noch jemand, Leute?
Norton Internet Security Suite?
Ja, ja, genau.
Wo ist das Screenshot? Genau, ja, ja.
Ja, oh man.
Das waren noch Zeiten, wo man sich mit seinem DSL-Modem direkt an das Internet angestöpselt hat.
Also, das werden vielleicht die wenigsten noch kennen.
Aber das waren Zeiten, da hatte man keinen Router mit NAT davor.
Man hat das DSL-Modem, am Anfang von DSL, man hat das DSL-Modem direkt an die Netzwerkkarte vom PC angeschlossen und sich dort eingewählt.
Das heißt, der PC selbst hatte eine Public-Internet-IP.
Und ihr könnt euch jetzt überlegen, was für eine doofe Idee es ist, einen Windows, ja, XP-Rechner, war es wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil damals,
einen Windows XP-Rechner, erste Generation,
ohne irgendwas, ungeschützt mit einer Public-IP ins Internet zu stellen.
Da gab es ja damals sogar so Untersuchungen, so nach dem Motto, wie lange dauert es, bis ein frisch installierter, ins Internet gestellter PC infiziert ist?
Das hat am Ende irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 25 Sekunden gedauert oder so.
25 Sekunden!
Also, das konntest du komplett knicken.
Ja!
Und da hast du so Kram gebraucht.
Damals gab es das hier.
Und was ich damals hatte, bei mir auf dem Rechner, war...
Gibt es das noch?
Gibt es noch Zone-Alarm?
Das ist total aus der Mode gekommen.
Okay, das gibt es sogar noch.
Guck mal, das gibt es noch.
Ach, Checkpoint ist das jetzt.
Okay.
Zone-Alarm, ja.
Warte mal hier.
Zone-Alarm Windows XP.
Für alle...
Das kennen die einen oder anderen auch.
Mal gucken für die...
Installing Zone-Alarm.
V12.
Ja.
Ich hoffe, man sieht das Interface gleich auch noch.
Damals war es schon Checkpoint?
Ja!
Genau, ja.
Aber, das sah...
Das...
Das, was ich...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Moment.
Lass uns die älteren Sachen angucken.
Okay, da gibt es...
Gibt es keine...
Ja.
Zumindest...
Das...
Das war damals...
Eines...
Ja, so sah das aus!
So gelb!
Genau.
Ja, ja, ja.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das...
Das war schon das neue Interface.
Das so gelb mit dem Stop-Button und sowas.
Genau.
Zone-Alarm.
So sah das damals aus.
Da konntest du auch Firewall-Regeln machen und sowas.
Und du wurdest...
Du wurdest...
Genau.
Du wurdest immer...
Wenn du irgendein neues Programm gestartet hast, was versucht hat, aufs Internet zuzugreifen,
wurdest du immer gefragt, so...
Möchtest du das zulassen, dass dieses Programm aufs Internet zugreift?
Ehrlich gesagt, war dieser Schutz damals schon für den Arsch.
Das Einzige, wofür diese Firewalls gut waren, aber was die 0815-Loop-Benutzer, ich bin
ja eingeschlossen damals, zumindest am Anfang, nicht gecheckt haben, ist, diese Firewalls
sind nicht unbedingt gut darin, ausgehenden Traffic zu blockieren.
Diese Firewalls sind ganz nützlich darin, ungefragt eingehenden Traffic zu blockieren.
Das ist das Problem, was du damals mit frischen Windows-Installationen im Internet hattest.
Da war irgendwelche...
Irgendwelche...
Ähm...
Port C, Port 445 und sowas offen, wo du sofort infiziert warst drüber.
Die Firewalls waren gut dafür, einfach jeglichen eingehenden Traffic zu blocken.
Übrigens, dieses Disaster, was Windows XP zu Release da hatte, mit diesen Anfälligkeiten,
das war ja auch der Grund, warum Microsoft damals Windows XP...
Äh...
Wie ist das?
Service Pack 2, glaube ich, rausgebracht hat.
Windows XP Service Pack 2 war ja ein mehr oder weniger neues Windows.
Da kamen auch sehr viele Sachen dazu, zum ersten Mal.
Wie beispielsweise diese...
Die Windows Firewall und sowas.
Ja, so sah...
So sah Sound Alarm damals aus.
Incoming NetBIOS is blocked!
Das wäre heute überhaupt kein Problem, das wieder öffentlich ins Internet zu stellen,
weil ich glaube, das probiert heutzutage kein Hacker mehr, ein Attacker mehr,
da irgendwas über NetBIOS zu machen, ey.
Ja, gut.
Gut.
Kommen wir mal...
Kommen wir mal zurück zum...
Zum eigentlichen...
Aber Sound Alarm!
Auch so ein Ding damals.
What's up with that?
And when you look at any other like best one, they're always at the top here.
That's because they pay the highest...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, also bei diesen Seiten muss man sich ja auch nicht wundern,
das sind so Toplisten, da würde ich nichts drauf geben.
...Rips.
I think some of the rips are going up as high as 50%.
So if you pay $100 to them, your favorite influencer just got a $50 kickback.
So that's kind of a fun one.
But they are awful antiviruses.
Their detection rates, again, on par with Windows Defender, but you're paying through
the nose.
Also, you have a lot of lock-in or vendor lock-in with these guys, because they offer
a suite of products.
Don't ever bundle in like a password...
Ich hatte auf dem Rechner, als ich mal vor einem Jahr oder so bei meinem Vater am Rechner
war, der hatte sich auch, ich glaube, AVG oder sowas installiert.
Und du konntest den Scheiß gar nicht richtig mehr deinstallieren.
Da musste ich auf meinem Handy tatsächlich googeln.
How to remove AVG antivirus.
Ich glaube, AVG war das.
How to remove.
Da musstest du quasi abgesicherter Modus starten, um das dann zu löschen.
So ein Bullshit, Alter.
Ich glaube, es war AVG.
...manager with your antivirus.
I really, really highly caution against that.
And these things are just so heavy.
And they make your computer run a lot slower, slower than any virus would make your computer
run a lot slower.
Slower than any virus would make your computer run.
So I treat them almost like a virus these days.
And they are by far the worst.
They're honestly the only one that are going to make this tier.
Moving on.
The rest of these have their time and place.
So I kind of go over them.
Now that we kind of set up the worthless ones, the okay, hey, everyone uses this.
Let's go with like, I think this is F-Secure here.
F-Secure.
Hab ich auch nie benutzt.
Ich würde es wirklich kaufen.
Kind of thing.
Ja, ich verstehe nicht, warum heute irgendjemand Antivirus kauft.
Für Windows-Desktop-PCs wohlgemerkt.
Wenn jetzt beispielsweise irgendein Unternehmen der Meinung ist, sie wollen ein Samba-Files
hier regelmäßig scannen und wollen dafür unbedingt sich bei den Comrades eine Kaspersky-Lizenz
kaufen.
Ja, go for it.
Meinetwegen.
I also had some experiences back in 2016.
I worked on a big business, actually had a ViperCon.
Was ist das?
Contract.
Viper?
And we had to deal with their business suite.
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
I think it was just a ton of licensing.
Was ist das?
Kennt ihr das?
Viper Anti-Virus.
But why?
I found them to be okay, I guess, but their detection rates were really poor back then.
And overall, not something I'd recommend.
Honestly, I think Windows Defender probably would be even better than them.
So that's kind of my thought process there.
Hey, also Artikel.
Ich glaube, ich würde es mal in die Kategorie Bitdefender nehmen.
Sie haben einen freien Modell, ein freies Virus.
Es ist auf der gleiche Art wie Bitdefender.
Ich würde es nicht besser oder schlimmer nennen, sondern ich würde es eher in die Mitte
legen.
Und weil ich Bitdefender mag, habe ich nichts schlechtes zu sagen davon, aber ich habe
keine wirklich tollen Dinge zu sagen von ihnen.
Ich werde sie also einfach in die A-Kategorie nehmen.
ESET war der Marktführer, sonst wäre ich es nicht.
Es ist so komisch, dass wir jetzt auf dem Internet nicht reden können.
Es ist so komisch, dass wir das nicht machen.
Es ist so komisch, dass wir das nicht machen können.
in der Mitte. Und
while I like Bitdefender,
I don't have anything bad to say about him, but I don't
really have a whole lot of great things to say about him
either, so I'm just going to put him in the A-Category.
ESET
has been a market leader,
otherwise known as NOD32 back in the
day.
Das packt ja nicht wirklich in Est hier, oder?
Not Antivirus, ja, da kann ich
mich noch dran erinnern. Tatsächlich, das gab's
früher auch.
Ja, aber Ecos, da kannst
du auch einfach Windows Defender eingeschaltet lassen.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn du bei der Oma nicht
gucken willst, dann gibt der Oma irgendeinen Linux
mit einem Browser drauf, damit kommt die Oma auch
klar. Die Oma will ja nix machen.
Und das
Wichtigste, genau, Janu, ich wollte's
grad sagen, das Wichtigste ist
tatsächlich irgendein halbwegs sicher eingestellter
Browser. Früher war's
NoScript.
NoScript in der Form gibt's ja glaube ich
nicht mehr, so seit
Firefox die ganzen
damals schon die ganzen Plugin-APIs abgeschaltet
hat, gab's hier, gibt's ja NoScript
in der alten Form nicht.
Nicht mehr. Aber U-Block ist schon mal
was ganz Praktisches.
So, nicht zu schlecht.
Malwarebytes, you know,
a lot of people that have removed a lot of
viruses.
Das gibt's auch noch. Die hatten doch früher,
wie hieß das denn?
Gab es nicht diesen
Trojaner-Scanner früher von Malwarebytes?
Wie hieß das Ding?
Weiß das noch jemand?
Das ist das,
wo die Leute früher immer gesagt haben,
lass mal einen Scan von
Malwarebytes oder sowas laufen
und dann poste den Report hier.
Anti-Malwarebytes?
War das das? Ja, kann sein.
Ja, kann sein.
Nee, nee, nicht.
In the day have used Malwarebytes
extensively. I don't recommend
you continually run it
with a monitoring of Malwarebytes
in the background. I don't find that
to be very good. However, Malwarebytes
is still very good at detection, so
when I'm cleaning a system, Malwarebytes
still gets used quite often.
Same goes for Sophos.
Ach, die gibt's ja auch noch.
Und I really...
Bei Sophos denke ich immer an irgendwelche super teuren
Appliance-Dinger.
...don't like their antivirus, but their scan
is probably one of the most in-depth scans
on the net. And I really love
mixing in them when scanning
for viruses. And they have a great
free scan. By the way, die letzten zwei Logos
habe ich noch nie im Leben gesehen. Was ist das?
...out on the market. So Sophos really gets
a good vote for me.
WebRoot, you know, I've talked...
Kenne ich nicht. WebRoot?
...talked about it.
...talked about it in the past.
I really like WebRoot. Their detection rates are
actually less than a lot of these A-Tier ones.
But their Secure Anywhere
Business Suite I've actually used
for, you know, probably five or six years
in some client sites. Very
minimal, very good, but I
only use the antivirus and I also
disable many of its advanced features
such as an exploit that came out with
WebRoot, Scare Anywhere, where
I think some people are exploiting... WebRoot habe ich noch nie gehört.
...the scripting aspect of it.
So, be cautious with this.
If you go that route, but I do love
its central management console, very
lightweight, very easy to manage
and honestly has really good
detection rates. In the same...
Ja, okay, aber wenn man das jetzt aus Windows,
aus Business-Sicht beurteilt, ja,
dann ist das ja eh wieder was komplett anderes.
...realm, Trend Micro used to be
really good, you know, 10, 15
years ago. I used them all the time,
but... Naja.
...slowly they kind of just...
Naja, ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht.
Naja.
Würde mir auf meinem Desktop nichts
anderes interessieren, als...
Was heißt installieren?
Nichts anderes zusätzlich draufmachen,
als Windows Defender und fertig.
Kaputt durch Unterforderungen.
Bore out.
Also, da kann man Abhilfe schaffen.
Handy raus, Discord auf, Reddit, Twitch.
Aber ja, im Prinzip ist es sicherlich
kacke, wenn du acht Stunden da sitzt
und nicht langweilst.
Also wisst ihr?
Wisst ihr, was ich mir als Kombination,
was ich mir richtig kacke vorstelle?
Wenn du dich langweil...
Also die Kombination aus
Langeweile, aber so tun müssen,
als ob.
So nach dem Motto,
ich kann nicht einfach öffentlich da sitzen
und den ganzen Tag Twitch gucken,
so nach dem Motto, ich hab nix zu tun,
sondern immer, wenn jemand ins Büro reinkommt,
schnell Twitch schließen müssen
und dann irgendwie...
Aha, aha, aha, bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla.
Jaja, okay, aber da geht der Typ raus,
aber er wird Twitch wieder auf.
Ja, das ist abfuck.
Da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Wenn ich lange genug gemeckert hätte,
dass ich nix zu tun hab
und mein Chef dann sagt,
ja gut, können wir auch nix machen,
dann würde ich halt einfach öffentlich Twitch gucken.
Okay, lass mal kommen.
Aber ich guck mir jetzt keine...
Ich guck mir jetzt keine 28-Minuten-Doku an.
Bei mir dauert das wieder drei Stunden.
Was ist das denn hier?
F...
Habt ihr schon mal einen so großen PC gesehen?
Es ist ein Doppelt...
Socket.
Wie nennt sich das?
Dual-Socket-Xeon-System, so wie es aussieht.
Von...
Tja, ja, steht ja hier.
Früh in 2000 dann.
Super fettes Ding.
Von der Farbe her ein bisschen wie alte Sun-Systeme.
Die waren ja auch...
Also eine Sache muss man ja mal den alten Servern wirklich zugute halten.
Auch wenn ich mir hier...
Oh, war das SCSI-Festplatten, Leute?
Das ist ja richtig...
Ja, oder?
Oder?
Ja, das waren die Daten für das 68...
Ultra-SCSI-Karte da.
Ja, ja, ja, das SCSI.
Okay, das ist richtig alt.
Das ist wirklich aus den frühen 2000ern.
Also eins muss man ja sagen, was die Hardware damals hatte, ist...
Das war wirklich richtig robust.
Also damit konntest du...
Gut, Leute, erschlagen kannst du mit aktueller Hardware, wenn es drauf ankommt, auch noch.
Aber die war so robust, damit...
Die kannst du aus dem Flieger werfen fast schon, ja?
Und du kannst danach immer noch was recoveren davon.
Die waren super robust, auch schwer, die Dinger.
Ah, der gute...
Gute alte Parallelport für den Drucker.
Es gibt heute noch Mainboards, die haben den.
Ich sehe immer mal wieder, gerade günstige Billig-Mainboards, die haben den.
Vier maximal.
Für was? Ich weiß es nicht, für was.
Hat doch irgendjemand einen Drucker, der über Parallelport angeschlossen wird, Leute?
Und selbst wenn, da gibt es doch garantiert, da gibt es doch garantiert Adapter für...
Guck mal mal, ähm...
USB to Paralleladapter.
Ja.
Guck mal, das ist sogar USB, auf dem die komischen Druckeranschlüsse da...
Ah, Nadeldrucker in Arztpraxen, okay.
Ja, aber dann würde ich auch einen USB...
Dann würde ich auch so einen USB auf Parallel verwenden.
Braucht es das Mainboard nicht mehr.
Aber man sieht damals auch schon drei Netzwerkeanschlüsse.
Ich vermute, wenn das ein Server-System ist, dass einer der Netzwerkanschlüsse die Konsole ist.
Vermutlich die hier...
Ne, Moment, das ist...
Sind das SFP-Stecker?
Leute, sind das...
Was ist das da unten?
Sind das SFP-Stecker? Was sind das?
Was sind das überhaupt?
Ich erkenne das nicht.
Das sind Aeon 45, wirklich?
Die sehen so flach aus.
Aber wenn das zwei Aeon 45 sind, dann ist das wahrscheinlich die Konsole hier oben, auch wo die Tastatur ist.
So einen Nadeldrucker könnte man doch zur Tätowiermaschine umbauen.
Da habe ich mir noch keine Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Und Nadeldrucker sind auch was, wo ich ehrlich gesagt gar keine Ahnung habe, wie die genau funktionieren.
Ähm...
Stimmt.
Und hier hast du zwei LEDs dran.
Ja.
Ja, aber das finde ich nice, dass der alte Hardware so super robust ist.
Man sieht auch schon hier damals doppeltes Netzteil möglich.
Hat er jetzt nicht.
Wundert mich.
Aber auch schon Dual-Netzteile, das ist ja heute auch noch Standard bei Servern.
Was haben wir denn hier sonst drin?
Okay, nur zwei unterschiedliche Lüfter?
Das scheint mir so, als hat da schon einer ein bisschen dran rumgebaut.
So, und...
Da hat er auch noch ein bisschen...
Also das ist doch bestimmt nicht Default, oder?
Zwei unterschiedliche Lüfter auf dem CPU.
Weil die werden ja schon die zwei gleichen CPUs sein.
Das ist ein Dual-Socketboard.
Jede Menge RAM-Riegel.
Da haben wir uns noch jede Menge Chipsatz-Dinger.
Und was haben wir hier?
PCI.
Dreimal.
Und das da unten könnten fast noch ein ISA-Slot oder sowas sein.
So sieht der PC von innen aus.
Die LEDs abgezogen sind, weil das innen jetzt aus der Halbdauer raus.
Ich muss das mal zeigen.
Stimmt.
Das ist ein Extended-PCI-Port.
Das ist kein normaler PCI-Port.
Der ist gefühlt...
Oh, wobei.
Der ist ein bisschen hier hinten ein bisschen lang für einen normalen PCI-Port.
Richtig?
Der sieht ein bisschen zu unförmig aus.
Wobei, ich kann mich nicht mal richtig dran erinnern, wie genau PCI...
Ja, genau.
PCI war da hinten auch noch so in so einem kurzen...
Was ist das?
Server-ASMA hier, Leute.
Und hier unten...
Hört mal.
Server-ASMA.
Ist ein normaler PCI-Slot und ein...
Server-Cringle-Sounds-ASMA.
Das ist ein SMDC-Connector.
Wenn jemand weiß, was dieser SMDC-Connector ist...
SMDC-Connector habe ich schon nie gehört.
Hier hinten sehen wir halt noch den Kürbis-Tipp von diesem Mainboard.
Und generell, dieses Mainboard ist einfach wahnsinnig gigantisch.
Hier eine Hand zum Vergleich.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen groß.
Ich hole mal kurz ein normales ATX.
Das ist ein normales Full-Sized-ATX-Board.
Wenn ich das jetzt hier so reinlege, sehen wir...
Das ist richtig groß.
Gut, aber das war die Technik von damals.
Und es waren Dual-Socken.
Und es war ein Server-Board, wo noch irgendwie eine Konsole und alles drauf ist.
Server-Boards sind heute auch noch ein bisschen größer.
Aber die hatten wir damals schon größer, ja.
Aber es ist...
Ach, deswegen einen Lüfter getauscht.
Sieben.
Netzteil.
Oh.
Pass mal auf.
Hört ihr, hört ihr den...
Die meisten Server drehen ja tatsächlich ein bisschen runter, nachdem sie einmal gepostet haben.
Alter, was hat der denn da für ultra-oldschool-Dinger hier im Hintergrund am Start?
Und die Lautstärke im Raum hat sich schon erhöht.
Das sieht aus wie so ein Ding, wo der Bademeister seine Durchsagen drüber macht.
Ich lasse das jetzt mal umgeschnitten, wie lange der zum Booten braucht.
Ja, das dauert.
Man muss sagen, es gibt heute auch noch Server.
Und die richtig eklig langsam booten.
Also, der für mich, der Worst Offender, sozusagen, was Bootzeiten angeht, waren...
Plate Center, Plates, HS, glaube ich, 23 oder HS 22, HS 21.
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau.
Ich glaube, HS 22 zu Release.
Die Dinger haben ohne Scheiß 5, das ist kein Witz, 5 Minuten gebootet.
Ja.
Kennt ihr noch jemand, die Teile, die mit der Release-Firmware-Version?
Die haben so ewig gebootet, das war ein...
Ey, das war so abartig.
Gerade, ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, wir hatten ein paar Linux-Kisten darauf laufen.
Und wenn da halt wirklich mal was war, musstest du halt auch mal in Bootmanager.
Und du musstest dem Ding 5 Minuten zugucken, beim Booten, dass du nicht den Moment verpasst hast,
dass du nicht den Moment verpasst hast, dass du nicht den Moment verpasst hast, dass du nicht den Moment verpasst hast,
wann du im Crab eine Taste drücken musstest, um dann die Bootline zu editieren.
Warum er das stehen hat, weiß ich auch nicht.
Bin ich aber auch schon gewundert, was da rumsteht.
Das waren wirklich die Abarten, also die Boots, das war echt jenseits von allem, die Seiten.
Post, Big Screen.
Also die booten richtig langsam, die Dinger.
Gerade, wenn die noch jede Menge Onboard-Sachen haben.
In der Zeit wäre ein aktueller Rechner schon dreimal hochgefahren.
Ein aktueller Server vielleicht nullmal?
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber das dauert ewig.
Das dauert wirklich ewig, das Zeug.
Der checkt jetzt jeden einzelnen RAM-Slot.
Das ist nicht so, dass er einen Ami-BIOS hat.
Windows-Server.
Wie kann man so ein altes Ding so versauen, Leute?
Warum ist da nicht wenigstens ein Debian?
Ja, was war denn da so aktuell?
Woody oder sowas?
Was war denn so um die Zeit?
Was war denn so um die Zeit aktuell, Mann?
Keine Ahnung.
Edge?
Woody, Woody wahrscheinlich, ja?
Irgendein olles Debian oder so drauf sein.
Booten wir in Windows Server 2003.
Also die Bootzeiten gingen noch voll klar bis jetzt.
Also das Playcenter wäre damals nicht über das RAID-Initialisieren raus...
...das HS22 mit Release...
...wäre nicht über RAID-Initialisieren raus gewesen.
Und irgendwie mag mein Monitor die Auflösung nicht.
Ah, das wird sich gleich wieder einpendeln.
Aber Windows booten ist jetzt auch nicht das Allerschnellste gerade.
Wenn ich Quick-Boot oder Quiet-Boot aktiviert habe, haben wir jetzt nicht die einzelne Initialisierung der RAID-Controller gesehen, sondern haben nur den Post-Screen gesehen und das wurde jetzt alles schon im Hintergrund gemacht.
Quick-Boot.
Und deswegen geht das jetzt etwas schneller.
Dauert natürlich noch immer noch ewig.
Drücken Sie STRG-ALT entfernt, um sich anzumelden, dann machen wir das mal.
Also, ich habe da so ein Herz für so alte Hardware.
Ich meine, ich bräuchte sie daheim nicht und ich würde sie auch nicht verwenden.
Aber ich gucke mir sowas gerne an und wenn ich irgendwo mal was sehen würde, würde ich da auch mal reingucken.
Aber haben will ich sie nicht, weil was willst du damit.
Du kannst damit nichts mehr machen.
Und der Nostalgie-Faktor ist ja dann auch recht schnell erschöpft.
Aber ich habe da irgendwie ein Herz für alte Hardware.
Herz für alte Art.
Weil genauso, wenn es um alte Sachen geht,
für Nagios, was Monitoring-Systeme angeht.
Ich mag Nagios. Niemand mag Nagios.
Ich mag Nagios noch.
Ich benutze es nicht, aber ich mag es noch.
Dieses hässliche Ding gibt es immer noch.
In aktuellen Windows-Server-Versionen.
Erinnert ihr euch noch dran,
wie sehr ich mich gequält habe mit
Windows-Server?
Ja.
Erinnert ihr euch noch dran,
wie sehr ich mich mit diesem Shit gequält habe?
So ein Schrott, Alter.
Jedes Mal, wenn ich mich mit Windows-Server auseinandersetzen muss,
muss ich kotzen, Alter.
Das ist so verplanter,
wirrer Scheiß.
Ich kann nicht verstehen, wie irgendjemand
freiwillig Windows-Server verwendet.
Was ist da drauf? 7-Zip.
Ey, das ist ja schon relativ aktuell, das Zeug, ja?
Ja.
Das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Also, ich meine, es ist uralt, ja?
Aber das ist für die damalige Zeit,
das ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Das ist ein Dual-Core-Xer,
und das heißt, es hat zwei CPUs?
Nee.
Das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht.
Es steht doch eindeutig ein Core nur da.
Wo steht, wo, wo, wo?
Mit zwei Kernen?
Nee, nicht zwei Kernen.
Ein Kern?
Zwei, zwei, zwei.
Das sind zwei CPUs mit jeweils
MX-Support, SSE-Support,
SSE-Support.
Ja, das sind, genau, das war noch
Pre-Multi-Core-CPU.
Ja, ja.
Das hier ist,
das ist aber nicht, das ist die erste
CPU und die zweite.
CPU gibt es nur ein Kern pro CPU.
Okay, dann ist es doch
wirklich Schrott.
Ich meine, vier Kerne wären immer noch,
immer noch irgendwie, ne?
Ja, was ist jetzt?
Ich meine, man darf es nicht unterschätzen,
das war damals absolut High-End-Shit, das Ding.
Und wie viel Rahmen haben wir?
Ey, was ist das?
32, ich würde ja sagen,
32 Gig, aber das Ding ist so alt,
vielleicht sind es auch nur 3 Gig.
3 Gigabyte, oder?
Ja, ich bin mir auch nicht sicher.
Was ist das denn?
Ich habe auch keine Ahnung.
Ich würde auch sagen 3 Gigabyte.
Ich würde auch sagen 3, aber...
3 Gigabyte, oder?
Ja, bin mir auch nicht ganz sicher.
Wenn wir jetzt den Windows Explorer öffnen,
sehen wir hier auch
HP-STSI-Rate 5.
Mit wie viel Gigabyte?
Man sieht es hier nebenbei.
Warte, warte, warte.
Jet 136 Gig,
kann das sein?
136 Gig?
Das ist richtig.
Ey, 136 Gig,
SCSI-Rate 5,
also sprich,
mindestens 3 Platten.
Das war auch schon...
Also, nicht billig.
Das sind hier vorne
diese Platten.
Ja, 3.
Und da haben wir hier insgesamt
136 Gigabyte.
Also,
also das Ding hatte wirklich Wumms
für die damalige Zeit.
Das dürfte tatsächlich
so 2003, 2004
vielleicht rum, oder 2003
rum, so das System. Ey, das ist,
das ist, oder sagen wir mal, eher 2002, 2003.
Das ist richtig
fett für die damalige Zeit.
Ja, aber das als Rate 5, ne?
Das ist schon echt eine Jone.
Ich schau jetzt mal nach, ob das hier...
War noch ein SCSI-Rate
damals. Das ist gut in meinem Server.
Naja, gut, mehr müssen wir uns
davon nicht angucken.
Heute hat Warzone
136 Gig, ja.
Stimmt.
Ups. Guck mal hier.
Heute, heute... Oder wie viel Gig hat Warzone
mittlerweile? Das reicht doch 136
nicht mehr, oder? Dann einfach wirklich
336.
Wie kann ich
mein Smart Home Sachen in einem extra
WLAN-Netzwerk stecken? Hab nur ne Fritzbox, gar nicht.
Fritzboxen können nur
ein WLAN
und ein Gäste-WLAN, wobei das Gäste-WLAN
dir für dein Smart Home Zeug wahrscheinlich
nix bringt. Wobei, ich lehne
mich vielleicht auch zu weit aus dem
Fenster. Vielleicht können
Fritzboxen mittlerweile
auch mehrere WLANs
oder mehrere SSIDs,
muss man ja eigentlich sagen.
Aber selbst das alleine bringt's dir
ja nicht. Du willst ja auch
netzwerktechnisch das Ganze beschränken. Das
heißt, dass deine Smart Home
Geräte aus dem Smart Home WLAN nicht
rauskommen. Oder nur zu
ganz bestimmten Sachen hin. Da weiß ich nicht, inwieweit
das mit der Fritzbox alles
easy möglich ist. Also ich hab's
so gemacht.
Ich hab ne normales
WLAN. Ich hab ne
IoT-WLAN. Und
die haben auch noch ein unterschiedliches
VLAN drunter.
Damit ich zum Beispiel
meine
Raspberry Pi
da reinstellen kann. Kabelgebunden.
Also ich hab zum Beispiel
für die
Kameras hatte ich früher
ein Raspberry Pi. Und da war
quasi im gleichen VLAN drinne,
wie die ganzen WLAN,
wie das Default, meine
Default WLAN SSID.
Das ist halt der Vorteil. Du kannst es
besser trennen, wenn du noch ein eigenes VLAN drunter hast.
Da kannst du dann auch kabelgebundene Geräte
reinpacken und sowas.
Und dann brauchst du ein paar gescheite
Firewall-Regeln, dass die Sachen nur
hin dürfen, wo sie hin sollen.
Am besten ist, wenn IoT-Sachen nirgends
wohin dürfen.
Gerade wenn da noch die original China-Chinesen-Firma
drauf ist. Inwieweit sich das
alles mit der Fritzbox realisieren lässt?
Keine Ahnung. Ich schwa, es ist nett.
So, was können wir uns als nächstes
angucken? Was haben wir denn hier?
Was erfolgreiche Programmierer tun und du wahrscheinlich
nicht?
Das klingt ein bisschen nach nem G-Bay-Titel.
Schau mal,
da sollen wir hier gucken.
Guck mal hier, es hört ja gar nicht mehr auf.
Jetzt haben wir doch schon geguckt.
Okay, was hat das für Probleme?
Welchen Router
du dann brauchst?
Ein Router alleine wird es dir wahrscheinlich nicht
reichen. Du brauchst
auch
entsprechende
Access-Points.
Kann man so pauschal nicht sagen.
Also ich hab ne Kombination
aus, man sieht,
wisst ihr, das sieht man in meinem letzten Video witzigerweise
ganz gut. Das ist da zwar überhaupt nicht dafür gedacht.
Hallo Leute, hier ist der Max.
Also hier sieht man
also einmal mein Switch.
Gucken wir mal, ob man den vielleicht ein bisschen besser sieht,
wenn ich den hier so...
Also man sieht einmal mein Switch.
Das ist ein Ubiquiti
Edge Switch 16 ES
16 XG oder so heißt
das Ding.
Das ist
für
10 Gig.
Reiner 10 Gig Switch.
Der aber natürlich auch
1 Gig, 2,5 und 5 Gig
kann. Aktuell sieht das
bei mir so aus. Das hier ist
10G
zum
Fileserver und
das hier 10G
als Uplink zu nem kleineren
Switch, den ich hier neben stehen hab.
Noch.
Das hier sind tatsächlich nochmal
drei
ältere
SFP 1 Gig
Ports, die ich
hier in die SFP Plus Slots reingesteckt
habe.
Und das sind
4x10 Gig
AJ45 Kupfer
wovon glaube
ich alle bis auf einen
auch nur mit einem Gig
gesynct sind. So zumindest das ist mein
interner Switch, der ist jetzt gar nicht so relevant dafür.
Ich hab als Router
Schrägstrich Paketfilter
Firewall, so ein Hex PoE
am Start.
Die Anschlüsse sind folgendermaßen.
Hier ist
ich hoffe ich krieg das jetzt richtig hin.
Hier ist die
hier ist das Juni, also das, das
Rosa Kabel, das ist jetzt wegen der
Beleuchtung nicht so richtig rosa, sondern
bisschen ganz leicht rosa. Das rosa
Kabel geht an die Unity Media Box
für Internet.
Das
grüne Kabel geht glaube
ich intern
an Switch hier oben irgendwo hin.
Und die anderen drei,
die anderen zwei,
ich bin mir gar nicht mehr sicher, wo er jetzt ist.
Die anderen
zwei
gehen auf jeden Fall zu
WLAN Access Points.
Der eine WLAN Access Point
ist im Keller. Der andere
WLAN Access Point hängt drüben
im Wohnzimmer an der Decke.
Und
habe ich gesagt grün? Blau.
Blaue Kabel meine ich.
Ja. Also das Ding verwende
ich, da habe ich ein paar Firewall Regeln drinne.
Und da sind auch die
ganz angelegt, wobei man halt sagen muss,
das Mikrotik Zeug ist nicht unbedingt
super einsteigerfreundlich von der Konfiguration
her. Da gibt es bestimmt
bessere Sachen, um ein eigenes
IoT WLAN aufzumachen.
Ich habe keinen Bock jetzt irgendein Schaubild zu malen.
Also, ja, können.
Weil ihr es seid, komm her.
Draw IO, die nicht mal
ein Draw IO heißt. Was
kennt ihr für gute Alternativen zu Draw IO?
Excalibur gab es da noch.
Das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Gibt es da bestimmt tausend Sachen mittlerweile.
Aber wir nehmen hier.
Ha. Habe ich noch irgendwas
Olles von mir.
Bau mal den Packet Tracer nach.
Mache ich jetzt nicht, aber habe ich überhaupt noch
habe ich das überhaupt noch drauf?
Ne, Packet.
Packet Tracer.
Tatsächlich gibt es sogar zum
installieren. Kackel.
Nice. Und man braucht ja da
mittlerweile einen Account für, aber das ist ein
kostenloser Account.
Also bei mir sieht das mittlerweile
so aus, ich lösche
die Wolke behalte ich mal und den
Router hier unten behalte ich auch.
Ich lösche das mal. Also bei mir sieht das
Netzwerk technisch so aus.
Ich habe
Machen wir mal alles weg.
Machen wir auch mal weg.
Also ich habe hier eine
Moment nochmal.
Fritzbox.
Ex PoE.
Switch.
Ist aber eigentlich kein Switch.
Ist es nicht so, dass
das laut Cisco das Router Bild ist
und Switch so Pfeile nach links und rechts hat nur?
Gibt es nicht.
Na komm.
Sind wir mal Netzwerk technisch nicht so
korrekt.
Access Point.
Wir suchen einfach nach WLAN.
Wifi.
AP1.
AP2.
Also bei mir sieht das folgendermaßen aus.
Das schieben wir jetzt mal weg.
Also Switch. Wir fahren mal mit dem Internet.
Interner Switch ist easy.
Interner Switch. Da ist zum Beispiel mein
Desktop PC dran und
alles mögliche interne Zeug.
Ich mach mal stellvertretend hier ein paar Kisten.
Egal. Spielekonsole.
Also interner.
Interner Switch.
Da verwende ich weder WLANs noch sonst was.
Interner 10 GB
10 GB Switch.
Da ist das ganze Zeug dran.
Was ich hier intern habe.
Der kann zwar VLANs und alles.
Aber keine VLANs oder sonst was.
Einfach rein für internen
Traffic. Der auch schnell sein muss.
Und auch zum Fileserver mit 10 GB und sowas.
So. Dann ist in der Mitte
von dem ganzen so ziemlich der Hex PoE.
Der ist einmal verbunden intern.
Da können wir auch gleich noch mal
eine Firewall suchen. Da gibt es bestimmt noch ein schönes Firewall
Bildchen. Machen wir hier noch eine
Firewall mit dabei. So. Okay.
Router. Router
Schrägstrich Firewall und alles
mögliche machende.
So. Der geht dann einmal
zum oder Phone
Box.
So. Der geht einmal ins Internet.
Der geht einmal ins Internet.
Und
hier im gleichen Netz
im gleichen Netz
ist noch mal eine Fritzbox.
Die Fritzbox verwende ich tatsächlich
nur für eine Sache.
Und das ist
VoIP und
DECT Telefone. Sonst macht die bei mir nichts.
Ach ja. Aber das stimmt nicht ganz.
Über die streue ich auch
die Fritz
Thermostate an.
Die macht aber sonst
nichts großartiges. Deswegen steht die auch in diesem
eigentlich äußeren
Netz.
Die Fritzbox kommt nirgendswo hin.
Die ist nur für
VoIP, DECT und diese Thermostate zuständig.
Was ich machen könnte ist, ich könnte das
hier zusammenfassen. Ich könnte mir eine ordentliche Fritzbox
kaufen und die Vodafone Box
und die Fritzbox zusammenfassen. Ja. Das könnte ich machen.
So.
Und dann geht es weiter. Dann habe ich
die Access Points hier noch dran.
Zwei Stück.
Wohnzimmer.
Keller. Das sind aktuell
Rokus R710.
Die ich da habe.
Die habe ich gebraucht auf Ebay gekauft.
Und seit ich die habe, habe ich überhaupt
keine Probleme mehr mit
WLAN jeglicher Art.
Die Dinger sind schweineteuer,
aber gebraucht auf Ebay gehen sie.
Man kriegt aber bloß die älteren Modelle auf Ebay
gebraucht. Und dann kosten sie immer noch so viel
wie neu irgendeinen
Ubiquiti Access Point.
Aber ich finde
die taugen einfach.
Zwei Access Points.
Die hängen hier noch dran.
Access Points Keller.
Access Points Wohnzimmer.
Und diese Access Points
läuft der Gäste weder ein Ticket Champ
noch.
Der ist dafür auch gar nicht gedacht gewesen.
Was wir mal im Browser
gebaut haben, dieses Plugin für
diese Access Points.
Das ist das Browser Plugin.
Das habe ich immer noch zum Passwörter generieren.
Aber das ist ja eher für IoT Geräte gewesen.
So.
Dann haben wir einmal hier einen WLAN.
Wir machen das einfach mal so.
Das ist ganz normales
Geräte
WLAN.
Wenn wir das jetzt mal.
Und geben wir dem mal
ich weiß nämlich meine VLAN ID nicht.
VLAN ID
5.
Ich weiß es echt nicht gerade aus dem Kopf.
So. Und dann haben wir
noch ein zweites.
Noch ein zweites
WLAN. Das legen wir einfach mal hier oben
drüber.
Das ist
IoT WLAN mit WLAN ID
1.3.3.7.
Ob man sich das merken kann.
So. Und
Ich habe jetzt noch
einen Raspberry Pi hier stehen.
Kann man vergessen, dass ist ja kein Raspberry Pi.
Ist ja eigentlich ein gescheiter
das Bild für.
Kein Bock.
Aber irgendwie das da.
Board?
Ja irgendwie sowas hier.
Dann habe ich noch ein Raspberry Pi stehen.
Das ist aber ein Blödsinn.
Single Board Computer?
Ok. Das ist jetzt.
Das ist echt schlimm.
Gibt es kein Bild für man.
Ja genau. Das ist jetzt unser Raspberry Pi.
Ok.
Da habe ich ein paar von.
Aber nur. Oh ja nice.
Erkennt man. Erkennt man. Erkennt man richtig
gut alles.
So. Das ist hier der Raspberry.
Alter. Was ist das?
Kann ich vielleicht mal please
ordentlich was dran schreiben da jetzt?
So. Das ist der Raspberry Pi.
Genau so sieht der aus.
So und nicht anders. Alles klar.
So. Der Raspberry Pi
der ist jetzt
hier dran angeschlossen.
Also.
Nicht wirklich. Aber
Was ist denn das hier?
Der Raspberry Pi ist. Lass mal dran.
Ach das ist das letzte Kabel gewesen.
Ich weiß. Jetzt weiß ich mal wieder wo das dritte Kabel
hingeht.
Das geht tatsächlich an Raspberry Pi.
Hm.
So.
Das geht an Raspberry Pi.
Und der ist auch
Wlan ID 5.
Da läuft
zum Beispiel das Dashboard für meine
Überwachungskameras und sowas drauf.
Weil das am einfachsten
ist dort
so von den Wlan Geräten drauf zuzugreifen.
Ja. Ungefähr so.
Natürlich kommen noch
mehr Geräte dabei. Aber
zum Beispiel ist das auch nicht der einzige Raspberry Pi.
Aber so nennen sie.
So ungefähr sieht das bei mir aktuell
aus. Und wenn jetzt
sagen wir mal die
IOT
Geräte irgendwo hin müssen
dann dürfen die nicht. Die dürfen nicht ins Internet.
Also wenn
so ein IOT Gerät. Sagen wir mal zum Beispiel
hier irgendwie
Balb.
Wenn ich das richtig schreiben kann.
Wie schreibt man Balb für Glühbirne?
Bulb?
Ja. Ja wenn man da zum Beispiel
mit Herzchen drin so eine Glühbirne
hat. So eine
China
Chinesen
Lampe.
Wie macht man
den Draw IOT Farbe Text
Font Color.
Background Color muss weg.
China Chinesen Lampe
hier im IOT WLAN.
Die da drinnen ist.
Sagen wir mal
die muss jetzt irgendwo hin drauf zugreifen
um die Uhrzeit zu setzen.
Was bescheid. Das ist jetzt nur mal ein Beispiel.
Dann habe ich hier
eine Firewall Freischaltung drinnen die
NTP erlaubt. Zum Beispiel.
Oder nehmen wir mal was realistischeres.
Wir haben hier
eine
Steckdosenleiste.
Die
exakt
so aussieht.
China Chinesen
Steckdosenleiste.
Also ein ganz gutes Beispiel.
Haben wir
auch hier im IOT WLAN
drinnen. Und da ist es
jetzt so.
Die muss ja
hier unten ist meine
mein Home Assistant.
Der ist im Internet.
Und da läuft ja unter anderem. Nennen wir das einfach.
MQTT.
Jetzt kommt natürlich diese China Chinesen
Steckdosenleiste
nicht an den MQTT Server
hier unten dran.
Und da gibt es explizit nur für diese
eine Sache auf diese eine Ziel
IP und für dieses eigene Gerät
dann eine Firewall
Freischaltung. Wobei ich weiß nicht ob es für das eine. Doch wahrscheinlich.
Ich habe es nur für das eine Gerät gemacht.
Kommt dann direkt
eine Firewall Freischaltung dahin.
Allerdings
bei mir stellt sich das Problem gar nicht.
Weil ich habe die China Chinesen
Steckdosenleiste geflasht.
Und da mache ich mir wenig Gedanken.
Und dadurch
dass die geflasht ist. Könnte man die
wenn man will sogar daran hängen.
Aber ich glaube die meisten
selbst geflashten
IOT Sachen habe ich hier dran hängen.
Und das schöne hier
an dem ist.
Hier habe ich
DPSK mit
DPSK.
Das heißt jedes meiner IOT
WLAN Geräte hat ein eigenes Passwort
für das WLAN.
Und mal angenommen die Lampe geht jetzt kaputt.
Und ich schmeiße die Lampe weg.
Dann lösche
ich einfach
den
User. Ne User ist das falsche Wort.
Dann lösche ich einfach das
WLAN Passwort für die Lampe.
Und egal wer
das WLAN Passwort jemals aus dieser Lampe
wieder extrahieren
sollte. Kann damit nicht
anfangen und sich nicht mal mehr ins IOT WLAN
einloggen. Weil das gelöscht ist.
Also jedes einzelne WLAN Gerät wenn
zumindest die neu aufgesetzten
haben eigene Passwörter.
Also ein DMZ
WLAN. Ne DMZ
ist ja in der Regel immer Zugang
von Außen. Also
richtige DMZ ist etwas was sich
zwischen
zwei Firewalls befindet. Nämlich einmal
zwischen der Außen und der Innen Firewall.
Und quasi Traffic
von Außen nach
Innen auf die DMZ erlaubt.
Und von Innen in die DMZ.
Also nicht
wirklich WLAN DMZ.
Bei dir hat jedes IOT Gerät dasselbe Passwort.
Ja das ist ein Problem. Deswegen
eines der Sachen warum ich kein Ubiquiti
Ubiquiti mehr verwende.
Weil die sich seit Jahren
davor drücken das zu implementieren.
Das ist nicht mit
Radius. Ne. Und weil
die sich seit Jahren
davor drücken. Ach ja.
Die können das jetzt auch.
Nach 5 Jahren
haben sie es geschafft. Nice.
Moment.
Was ist Unify Network?
Ist das die
Ist das die Firmware?
Ist das die Firmware Version?
Da muss ich mal angucken wie die das da
Na finally alter.
Finally.
Alter die haben so lange. Ihr müsst
euch mal vorstellen. Die haben so lange dafür
gebraucht dass ich mir mittlerweile neue Access Points
von einem anderen Hersteller gekauft habe.
Äh.
Ne.
Moment.
Das ist was anderes.
Allow you to
use different Passwords on the same
one from
different virtual networks.
Nein. Das ist nicht Pro Client.
Das ist nicht Pro Client.
Die können das Pro WLAN.
Das ist auch schon wieder Schrott mann.
Das bringt überhaupt nichts.
Weil es das Problem nicht löst.
ist das löst das problem doch überhaupt nicht dass das eigentlich die eigentliche problemstellung ist
du hast ein gerät in einem wlan hängen in einem iot wlan ist auch egal was du hast du hast die
glühbirne hier oder die china steckdosenleiste in einem iot wlan so die geht kaputt du schmeißt
sie weg irgendjemand extrahiert ein wlan passwort hat raus und kann sich ein iot wlan einwählen und
von dort dann also es ist ja egal wie restriktiv das ist aber allein schon dass dieser schritt geht
und es ist auch erst mal egal wie wahrscheinlich das ist aber das ist ja die grundlegende
problemstellung die ist zu lösen gilt und damit lösen das problem löst du nicht mit unterschiedliche
passwörter pro wlan sondern das löst du mit unterschiedlich passwörter pro gerät dann musst du
dich wieder damit beschäftigen wie du unwiederbringlich deine geräte zerstörst und mal ganz im ernst
versuche
mal ja aber wpa enterprise können die meisten geräte nicht deswegen bringt das bringt es das
nicht wpa enterprise können die meisten geräte nicht mac adresse acl bringt es auch nicht kann
sie einfach auslesen von dem gerät also man kann beliebig drumherum doktoren um das problem oder
man löst richtig nämlich mit dpsk das geht seit dem letzten update das geht pro client aber dass
das sagt die
das change log sagt ist aber nicht
das change oder geht also in der noch neueren version also hier sieht man eindeutig nur
unterschiedliche passwörter profiler ein id und maman können wir doch mal was die hier dazu sagen
was bin ich hier überhaupt sehen gerade was was sie was was ich was ist uni hostet was soll das
sein wie host juni franz emergency cloud ok das ist im prinzip das gleiche was man auch selbst aus
kann ich würde den mal ein tipp geben für screenshots eventuell in der größe
wo man was erkennen kann auf der webseite nicht erst die man extra öffnen
muss passwörter configuration das geht nur pro wlan id und das ist halt scheiße
das kann man halt gebrauchen das löst das problem nicht
da steht wlan id 02 passwörter das steht network wlan id so das heißt du
kannst pro wlan id ein passwort vergeben was ja sinnlos ist du willst ja pro
geräten passwort vergeben du hast ja auch gar kein add button für neues gerät
oder sowas also wenn das geht ist die überfläche nicht nicht ein
hier sieht man es ja guck manual manual und jetzt pre-shared keys
ja du kannst du kannst nur die vlans auswählen du kannst das ist für ein
arsch man was haben sie was haben sie da wieder moment jetzt blick ist nicht also
doch du kannst doch mehrere ok du kannst es doch pro gerät machen aber warum
kannst du nicht dahinter schreiben für welches gerät das ist wie willst du das
jetzt wiederfinden ich stelle mal vor ich lege jetzt ein
passwort an und dann schreibe ich ein passwort an und dann schreibe ich ein
für glühbirne abc wie finde ich dann wieder glühbirne abc da kannst du
überhaupt keinen überhaupt kein text oder sowas hinten dran schreiben aber
das okay dann geht das doch dann ist die beschreibung einfach nur
absolut pepega und wie kannst du es locken lassen
also ich kann jetzt mal ich kann euch jetzt mal erklären wie das bei mir
funktioniert moment wir haben das doch wir haben das doch gebaut im stream
browser wie ist das denn wie ist das stream web interface moden genauer man sieht hier nicht also
bei mir sieht das bei mir das folgendermaßen aus ja ich meine access point hat auch nicht 1500
euro gekostet sondern auf ebay also bei mir sieht das folgendermaßen aus die anleitung die man hier
findet ist natürlich schon wieder komplett bescheuert es ist wieder findest wieder nichts
dazu man im prinzip ist das total simpel ja ja man findet keine gescheiten spielers also im
prinzip ist das simpel du klickst den web interface hinzufügen für neues gerät dort
lässt du dann lässt du dein passwort generieren du kannst dir noch ein qr code du kannst dir noch
ein qr code generieren lassen den ihr bei den geräten einscannen lassen kannst das
ist auch nice und dann merkt es sich beim ersten connect die mac adresse von dem gerät das heißt
es geht nur die kombination diese mac adresse mit diesem passwort und selbst wenn jetzt wenn
du das gerät weg wirft und dass jemand klaut dieses passwort ist ja gelöscht also spricht
du hast komplett das problem behoben sollte jemand das gerät wegwerfen sollte jemand das
gerät aus dem müll holen und den controller auslesen außerdem möchte ich noch mal darauf
hinweist es ist gar nicht so einfach geräte ordentlich zu zerstören überlegt guckt euch
mal so was an ihr habt ein davon hatte ich ein paar microcontroller so ein ganz kleiner
sp 32 microcontroller wenn ich wenn ich eines der kleinsten sp 32 microcontroller so leute
versucht war so ein ding ordentlich zu zerstören wenn ihr nicht die passende ins passende equipment
baut hat dann geht das schon mal los an welcher stelle bost du denn überhaupt wenn du dich damit
nicht weiter beschäftigt beschäftigt hast du an welcher an welcher stelle borst du hammer ich
würde mich nicht darauf verlassen wenn ich da mit dem hammert also erstens ist das ding ziemlich
robust und wenn du mit dem hammer drauf haust würde ich auch nicht unbedingt sagen dass du
gerade den speicher erwischt direkt dann kaputt ist also am besten wäre am besten wäre hexen
Ja, häckseln. Aber finde mal einen Häcksler, der sowas häckseln kann, daheim.
Du kannst ja nicht einfach in deinen Mixer schmeißen.
Da sind relativ stabile Metallteile dabei.
Einfach am besten wäre ein Häckseln oder Einschmelzen.
Das sind alles so nicht so richtig praktikable Sachen.
Also deutlich einfacher, deutlich einfacher einschmelzen, ja.
Aber deutlich einfacher ist es doch, das einfach wegschmeißen zu können
und sich überhaupt keine Gedanken darüber machen zu müssen,
weil das WLAN-Passwort eh nicht mehr gültig ist, oder?
Oder wir schicken es an den Hydraulic-Pressed-Channel, genau.
Der Hydraulic-Pressed-Dun, mein ESP32.
In die Sonne schießen oder in einen Vulkan werfen.
Sehr gute, praktikable Idee, Chat.
Easy.
Problem gelöst.
Auch sehr günstig, ja.
Auch sehr günstig.
Also ihr seht, die Probleme sind teilweise gar nicht so einfach zu lösen, wie man denkt.
Und so eine technische Lösung, dass das einfach nicht mehr möglich ist,
mit dem Passwort irgendwas anzufangen.
Ja, besser, oder?
Was ist das denn?
Mini-Schredder.
Ding des Monats.
Okay, dann lass mal schreddern.
Ja, wie, man sieht das jetzt gar nicht in Aktion?
Oh, das ist ja kein...
Kacke.
Das redet nicht richtig.
Da muss jetzt ja noch ein ordentlicher Motor dran, ne?
Das ist auch geschreddert.
Ein Stück Papier, man.
Ein Stück Papier kann ich mir auch mit was anderem schreddern.
Ein Stück Pappe kann ich auch mit was anderem schreddern.
Eine Karte krieg ich auch noch mit was anderem geschreddert.
So Metallteile, so USB-Anschlüsse und so.
Bin mir nicht sicher, ob das das Ding schafft.
Also ich glaube, das Ding hätte Probleme mit so einem ESP32-Board.
Okay, 3D gedruckt. Soll ich? Okay, okay.
Aber immer noch nicht, immer noch nicht in der Intensität, wie ich mir so ein ESP32-Board vorstelle.
Das ist auch sehr dünn.
Ich mein, die Dinger sind, ne? Also...
Die sind stabil.
Die Teile.
Die sind klein und die sind stabil. Allein schon die Metallanschlüsse hier drauf.
Und das ist auch nicht so dünn.
So PCBs und gerade so die Metallsacht, die sind schon echt stabil.
Also ich trau das dem Ding nicht zu, das ordentlich zu schreddern.
Chat, was meint ihr? Würde das Ding das hier schreddern?
Ich hätt meine Bedenken.
Gerade beim USB-Anschluss glaube ich nicht, dass es das ordentlich schreddert.
Natürlich. Ja, du hast das.
Du kennst dich mit Microcontroller, stell's aus.
Wie schredderst du deine Controller?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Es macht schon einen...
This shredder is a beast.
Jetzt gucken wir uns ernsthaft Schredder-Videos an.
Okay, das ist ein Schredder zum Handdrehen.
Ist natürlich auch nicht verkehrt.
Erstmal schön den Finger reinstecken.
Warum genau wird das hier geschreddert?
Oh Mensch, was es nicht alles gibt.
Dem Ding würde ich zutrauen. Wobei, das ist auch ganz schön...
Okay, wenn's das schafft, würde ich davon ausgehen, das schafft das Board auch.
Ja.
Das ist halt ein PCB mit USB-Anschlüssen und sowas.
Aber dem würde ich das zutrauen.
Okay, wenn es das schafft, dann schafft es mein PCB auf jeden Fall.
Guck mal, wie sich's windet. Wie sich's windet.
Oh...
Alter, das tut ja weh beim zugucken!
Okay, dem Ding würde ich zutrauen,
dass es auch...
...mein ESP32 shreddern kann.
RPV
Shredder in None
readys
Nun gut, also sowas wäre auch eine Möglichkeit, aber es ist doch deutlich besser, wenn die Geräte einfach nicht ins WLAN kommen.
Okay, was ist das hier? Was erfolgreiche Programmierer tun und du wahrscheinlich nicht.
Okay, ich kann euch sagen, was erfolgreiche Programmierer machen.
Erfolgreiche Programmierer, um das jetzt mal in den Kontext zu bringen.
Erfolgreiche Programmierer updaten ihre Software vielleicht öfters als alle zwei Jahre.
Die programmieren halt einfach auch mal.
Und lassen es sich rumgammeln.
Okay, wir gucken uns mal an, was erfolgreiche Programmierer machen, okay?
Ein erfolgreicher Programmierer von einem durchschnittlichen.
Du denkst vielleicht, es sind die klassischen Antworten, die wir auch von Google erhalten.
Zum Beispiel produktiv sein, lösungsorientiert arbeiten oder auch einfach nur Fristen im Griff haben.
Das Ding ist aber, wenn man halt fehlerfrei, ich wollte es gerade sagen, wenn man fehlerfreie Software entwickelt, was der Fiat Champ ja offensichtlich ist, wie man hier sieht.
Dann braucht man auch keine Updates, weil wenn es funktioniert, dann funktioniert es.
Das hier sind offensichtlich alles Anwendungsfehler.
Kann ich ja nichts für, wenn die Leute es einfach nicht benutzen können.
Das ist nur die Spitze des Eisberges.
In meiner Laufbahn habe ich drei entscheidende Gewohnheiten entdeckt, die die erfolgreichsten Softwareentwickler ausmacht.
Und diese Geheimnisse, die will ich heute mit dir teilen.
Okay, auf geht's.
Diese hätten mir nicht nur viele Stunden des Lernens erspart, sondern auch einfach mich glücklicher beim Programmieren gemacht.
Gute Software erkennt man am Preis.
Genau, es muss einfach nur teuer sein.
Deswegen ist SAP und Oracle auch das Geilste, was es gibt.
Lass uns gleich anfangen.
Vor allem SAP.
Mein verbreiteter Ratschlag, den ich damals als Anfänger häufiger hören musste, war dieser hier.
Um ein guter Programmierer zu werden, musst du täglich programmieren.
Und das hört sich im ersten Moment auch logisch an, denn Übung macht den meisten.
Nicht zwangsläufig, aber es hat echt, also ganz ehrlich, wenn man, okay, vielleicht nicht unbedingt, weil man ein guter Programmierer werden will,
aber wenn man ein erfolgreicher...
Programmierer werden will, dann bedeutet das ja auch, man hat Projekte, die in gewisser Weise erfolgreich sind.
Und da muss man schon am Ball bleiben, sonst endet das wieder Fiat-Champer.
Atheno, danke schön für den SAP.
Und außerdem gucken die gescheiten Programmierer regelmäßig Bublo aus, logisch.
Aber so einfach ist das nun auch wieder nicht.
Lass uns dafür kurz die Welt des Programmierens verlassen.
Pet?
Im C...
Was?
Ach nein, Fetty.
Mac Fettsack.
Jetzt hab ich verstanden.
McFly, Leute, danke schön für die ganzen SAPs.
Excellent.
Leute, any, any Piano Players?
Hier, wo hab ich denn mein...
Five Head Wine Emote?
Ich seh's gar nicht.
...Tour des Programmierers.
Er übt also stundenlang jeden Tag, denn...
Klavier-Enjoyer.
...Bublo macht den Meister, oder?
Er spielt immer die gleichen Stücke, die gleichen Tonarten, die gleichen Tonleiter, immer und immer wieder.
Anfangs macht er dadurch auch richtig schnell richtig viele Fortschritte, doch das sollte nicht für immer so bleiben.
Er übt zwar, aber übt er hier jetzt eigentlich wirklich?
Nach einer Weile stellt er dann auch fest, dass er so ein bisschen die Motivation für die Musik verliert
und...
...er spielt eigentlich nur noch aus Pflichtgefühl.
Was lernen wir jetzt daraus?
Es ist nicht die Menge des Übens, die zählt, sondern die Qualität des Übens.
Ich würd sagen, beides.
Ich...
Also, keine Ahnung.
Ich würd sagen, beides.
Man kann es jetzt nicht...
Sicherlich nicht so eins zu eins...
...übertragen...
...aus Programmieren, aber sagen wir mal auf was anderes.
Es gibt doch...
Wie heißt das?
Trainings...
...Pyramide oder sowas?
Trainingspyramide?
Nee, das mein ich nicht.
Training...
...Pyramide...
Ja, so sinngemäß.
Also, das Wichtigste ist regelmäßig.
Ich finde, ich finde...
Hier Beständigkeit, ja, hier trifft man das sowas in der Richtung.
Das Wichtigste ist regelmäßig.
Das ist das sowas in der Richtung.
Habe ich gemeint.
Das ist nicht genau das, was ich meine.
Aber das Wichtigste ist regelmäßig.
Die Sachen machen.
Total Frequency Volume of Training.
Das Wichtigste ist regelmäßig.
Ja, danach kann man sich...
Also, du kannst super krass die Gedanken machen.
Ja, und dir das super krasse Equipment kaufen.
Und das ganz tolle irgendwie Protein-Dinger und sonst was.
Derjenige, der fünfmal die Woche rennt.
Wird trotzdem nach einem Jahr deutlich fitter sein,
als jeder, der nur zweimal die Woche rennt
und super High-IQ-Training macht.
Selbst wenn der Typ einfach nur stumpf...
...fünfmal die Woche seine paar Kilometer rennt.
Wenn der andere nur zweimal rennt
und super High-IQ-Schuhe hat und was auch immer,
dann ist trotzdem der nach einem Jahr fitter,
der fünfmal rennt.
Also, Frequenz ist echt das Wichtigste.
Und ab einer gewissen Menge
wären natürlich andere Sachen wichtig, ja.
Ob es jetzt ein Riesenunterschied ist,
ob einer fünfmal oder sechsmal trainiert
versus dann die Feinheiten.
Da kann man sich drüber streiten.
Aber bei großen Quantitätsunterschieden
wird der, der einfach mehr macht,
auf lange Sicht auch der sein, der besser ist.
Nochmal ein anderes Beispiel.
Guckt euch mal klassische Musikkomponisten an.
Wo wir gerade bei Piano und Klavier waren und so.
Die meisten davon haben enorm viel Zeug rausgehauen.
Die waren super produktiv.
Die mussten, nicht alle, nicht alle, ja.
Aber die meisten, die meisten waren super produktiv.
Ich meine, die haben damit ja auch Geld verdient.
Und ganz vieles davon ist so richtig 0 auf 15.
Aber ein paar Stücke, so bei jedem Komponist,
die ragen halt raus.
Da hat er sich halt wirklich selbst übertroffen.
Aber trotzdem, die meisten haben massig Zeug rausgehauen
und haben dann aber auch den ein oder anderen
richtig, richtig, richtig bekannten Hit gelandet, quasi.
Ich sag das mit klassischer Musik,
weil das ist oft genug analysiert worden.
Ist heute bestimmt ähnlich noch.
Die Menge macht schon viel aus.
Warum sind dann alle bei LOL so scheiße?
Moment, du nicht.
Ich denke nur deine Teammates, oder?
Ich denke nur deine Teammates.
Am Anfang deiner Programmierkarriere ist es wirklich hilfreich, viel zu üben.
Denn hier erreichst du Qualität durch Quantität.
Aber nach einer gewissen Zeit musst du da strategischer rangehen.
Die fünfte To-Do-App, die ist vielleicht gut, um dir jetzt nochmal die...
Da hat er natürlich recht.
Wenn man nicht über Hallo Welt rauskommt, ist auch egal,
ob ich 20 Mal Hallo Welt mache.
Das ist schon klar.
Konzepte zu festigen oder auch einfach die Winter zu füllen.
Aber das kommt, also ganz ehrlich,
das kommt allein dadurch,
wenn es einen persönlich interessiert.
Wenn man das Thema nur macht, weil es in der Schule drankommt,
dann wird man da keinen Spaß dran haben.
Wenn einen das persönlich interessiert
und wenn man auch immer wieder so neue Gebiete hat,
die einen interessiert und in die man sich einarbeitet,
dann wird man auch immer wieder
sich mit neuen Technologien auseinandersetzen müssen.
Zum Beispiel, als wir im Stream,
haben wir doch mal so ein FFM-Pack
im Browser gebaut.
FFM-Pack mit, wie hieß das noch mal?
Also für WebAssembly.
Wie hieß das noch mal?
Mit irgendeiner C++-Library.
Mit irgendeinem C++-Cross-Compiler.
So.
Und das war was, das habe ich im Vorfeld noch nie gemacht.
Da habe ich enorm viel bei gelernt.
Das meiste habe ich mittlerweile wieder vergessen.
Aber warum? Weil es mich zu dem Zeitpunkt
brennend interessiert hat,
wie der Scheiß funktioniert.
Das meiste habe ich wieder vergessen.
Ich meine, ich habe den Source-Code noch irgendwo,
da könnte ich nachgucken.
Aber das ist immer so.
Und dann interessiere ich mich für Microcontroller,
dann interessiere ich mich für WebRTC
und dann macht man auch einfach mal
1, 2, vielleicht 3 Monate
ganz viel in diesem Thema.
Und weil es einen persönlich interessiert,
wird man dann auch ganz gut drin.
Also ich gebe ihm schon recht,
mit dem 500. Hello World kommst du nicht weiter.
Setzt dir klare Lernziele und wiederhol nicht ständig das Gleiche.
Okay, nächstes Thema.
Genauso wichtig.
Während meiner Studienzeit und während meiner Laufbahn
sind mir immer wieder Personen begegnet,
die so stolz darauf waren, wie gut sie doch
programmieren könnten.
Ja, dumme Schwätzer, immer.
Das sind dann meistens die Personen gewesen,
die gerade erst angefangen haben,
die ersten Basics gelernt haben
und vielleicht das erste einfache Projekt umgesetzt haben.
Speziell während meines dualen Studiums
ist mir das bei einem...
Also bei den Leuten, die immer am größten tönen,
dass sie die geilsten sind.
Zum Beispiel,
ich hatte ja jetzt in der letzten Firma
die ein oder anderen Azubis,
um die ich mich kümmern musste.
Und wir hatten welche,
die haben mir schon quasi in den ersten paar Tagen erzählt,
sie machen die Ausbildung ja eigentlich nur,
damit sie dann einen Abschluss haben
und sie können das alles
und der IHK-Abschluss,
der kommt halt nicht von alleine,
deswegen müssen sie jetzt die Ausbildung machen
und die wissen das schon.
Und das waren oftmals die Leute,
mit denen ich am größten Probleme hatte.
Weil das war so eine Kombination aus
von sich voll überzeugt,
aber meistens
kein Plan.
Das ist eine scheiß Kombination.
Dazu gehörte auch der Typ,
erinnert ihr euch noch an das Video,
was ich gemacht habe,
wo es um den Typ ging,
der versucht hat bei uns im Rechenzentrum
irgendeinen Filesharing-Dienst zu hosten?
Ja, gehörte da auch dabei.
Und er hat mir gesagt,
dass da mehr heiße Luft als wahre Worte hinterstecken.
Aber auch wenn du nicht prallst,
kann dieser Punkt auf dich zutreffen.
Hierzu ein kleines Beispiel.
In meinem Team war mal ein Werkstudent...
Nee, nee, nee, nicht mit dem Shit-Repo.
Mit dem Shit-Repo war Herr Endpunkt.
Mit Herr Endpunkt hatte ich auch meine Probleme.
Übrigens wisst ihr,
dass ich gestern mit Herr Endpunkt
Discord telefoniert habe, eine Stunde.
Und wir haben uns überlegt,
ob wir nicht mal
so ein...
Der Werdegang,
das Herr Endpunkt machen wollte.
Aber ich weiß,
da braucht man ein bisschen...
Ja, den meinte ich nicht.
Herr Endpunkt hat nie versucht,
bei uns im Rechenzentrum
illegale Filesharing-Sachen zu hosten.
Zumindest habe ich gehört,
der ist jetzt bei einer Bank in Frankfurt gelandet.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Irgendwie landen so früher oder später
alle bei irgendwelchen Banken in Frankfurt.
Und ist dort jetzt
verantwortlich für die
Oh, er hat es mir gestern erzählt.
Für irgendein
größeres IT-System.
Da hört man sich tatsächlich auch mal drüber.
Weil der hat echt einen ganz interessanten
Gang jetzt hinter sich.
Finde ich, weil
der hat ja keinen allzu guten
Start. Keinen allzu guten
Start bei uns.
Es war eines der wenigen Azubis,
der nicht übernommen wurde.
Er hat es auch richtig verkackt.
Ich glaube, es hat er auch mittlerweile eingesehen.
Er hat erst mal nichts gefunden.
Danach war er bei so einer Personalvermittlungsagentur
oder so einem Personalverschacherungs-Ding.
Und
zumindest hat er es jetzt geschafft,
wo zu landen,
was taugt.
Das letzte Mal, wo ich mit ihm telefoniert habe,
war er im IBM-Host-Umfeld tätig.
Aber macht er jetzt nicht mehr.
Hat ja auch nicht so wirklich große Zukunft.
Der ist ja noch jünger als ich.
Ist ja, keine Ahnung, wie alt er jetzt sein wird.
26, 27 oder so.
Ja, 28 vielleicht.
Um die 20.
Müsste jetzt 28 oder so sein.
Also, ungefähr so alt, wie ich mit YouTube angefangen habe.
Nein, nicht ganz. Da war ich schon ein bisschen jünger.
Wo ich arbeite, sage ich nicht.
Und
dort, wo ich Hähnepunkte in der Ausbildung
hatte,
arbeite ich auch nicht mehr.
Und dort, wo ich den Azubi hatte,
der Filesharing im Rechenzentrum
hosten wollte, da arbeite ich auch nicht mehr.
Meinung zu Uni-Absolventen in der IT.
Kommt auf den Uni-Absolventen an, oder?
Hahaha.
Was ist dieses Buchstaben kopieren?
Ja, richtig.
Von Max ist
kompiliert zu großes IT-System.
Ja, ist echt so bei ihm.
Hähnepunkt war derjenige,
dem ich als Aufgabe,
als Übungsaufgabe
gestellt hatte,
er soll einen BMI-Rechner programmieren.
So Konsoleneingabe.
Und ich meine, es ist wirklich nicht schwierig,
einen BMI-Rechner zu programmieren.
Sollte Konsolen,
Konsolenanwendungen sein,
so nach dem Motto, geben sie ihre Größe ein,
geben sie ihr Alter und Gewicht ein
und dann soll er einen BMI ausrechnen.
Also super simpel, das sind irgendwie, keine Ahnung, fünf Zeilen oder so.
Und da hat er irgendwie zwei Trage
dran rumgemacht und irgendwann ist er halt
zu mir gekommen und hat dann gesagt, Max,
ich hab's geschafft, es geht, es geht.
Und im Endeffekt hat er es halt das erste Mal
kompiliert.
Und dann hat er, er hat es halt nicht in Rust
programmiert. Hätte er es in Rust programmiert,
hätte es jetzt auch funktioniert.
Genau, und dann ist es gestartet.
Und da kam dann halt so eine Konso, ist halt, kam halt, ne,
kam halt eine Konsole.
Und da stand dann so was wie so,
geben
sie ihr Alter ein.
So, und
dann, dann hat er halt erwartet, dass ich dann
da eingebe, keine Ahnung, 29.
Und ich hab halt eingegeben, A, B, C und Enter gedrückt.
Und das Ding ist direkt gecrashed.
Nein, du kannst da doch nicht Buchstaben
eingeben.
Tja.
Dann hat er nochmal irgendwie zwei Tage...
Ich glaube, er hat es irgendwann aufgegeben.
Okay, was war der erfolgreiche Programmierer noch?
BMI-Rechner programmiert.
...einfache Aufgabe gegeben hatte.
Doch die Zeit verging und verging.
Es gab aber keinen so rechten Fortschritt.
Als ich dann nachgehakt habe, habe ich herausgefunden,
dass er sich einfach nicht so sicher
mit der von uns verwendeten Programmiersprache
gefühlt hat.
Ja, aber er hat sich nicht getraut, was zu sagen, weil er im Vorfeld
so groß rumgetönt hat, dass er alles schon kann.
Das ist halt auch doof.
Und er versucht, alle Probleme allein zu lösen.
Da solltet ihr in keinster Weise Werkstudenten
wäschen, denn von Anfängern und auch
von Fortgeschrittenen wird nicht erwartet,
dass sie alles wissen und...
Ehrlich gesagt, ganz im Ernst,
ich habe mittlerweile
mir das abgeschminkt,
in Bereichen, wo ich, wenn ich was nicht weiß,
so zu tun als wüsste ich.
Zum Beispiel,
ich meine, ich kann Ansible, ich kann Sachen in Ansible
erstellen, ich kann Ansible lesen, ich kann Ansible ausführen,
ich kann Ansible ändern, alles.
Was ich nicht weiß ist,
wenn ich ein großes Ansible-Modul vor mir habe,
wie man es benutzt
und was es genau macht.
Und meinte auch letztens irgendjemand,
ja, wie wäre es denn,
willst du nicht mal probieren,
die und die Server aufzubauen?
Und ich sagte, ja, wenn es das Server aufbauen wäre,
wäre das kein Problem.
Da brauchst du irgendwie 15 Ansible-Module,
von denen ich keine Ahnung habe, wie man sie benutzt
und was sie genau machen.
Also, du hast das schon gemacht, ich kenne die nicht,
also ich baue meine halbe Stunde auf,
das geht halt nicht, keine Ahnung von.
Aber es hat ja keinen Sinn,
dann zu sagen, ja, easy mache ich,
wenn es halt nicht easy ist.
Wenn ich das 2-3 Mal gemacht habe, ist das überhaupt kein Ding.
Zumal das nicht, dass unsere Ansible-Module
sonderlich
schön wären oder so, dass man die gut lesen könnte.
Außerdem bin ich eh nicht so der große Ansible-Enjoyer.
Ich finde Ansible ist ganz nice,
wir haben es ja auch im Stream schon ein paar Mal verwendet.
Aber wenn ich drum herum komme,
dann versuche ich drum herum zu kommen.
Also, wenn ich mit Terraform für Infrastetriebe
und Infrastruktur und Cloud-Init-File auskomme
für ein paar Sachen,
dann mache ich einen großen Bogen um Ansible.
Du musst nicht alles können, das stimmt.
Wichtig ist, man muss wissen, welche Leute man um Hilfe fragen kann.
Weil, kennt ihr die Situation,
dass ihr irgendwie nicht genau weiter wisst?
Aber ihr wisst auch,
wenn ihr jetzt irgendwo hingeht
und um Hilfe fragt,
dann ist das wahrscheinlich
deutlich langwieriger,
als wenn ihr einfach jetzt
eine Stunde googelt.
Also mal angenommen, es gibt irgendwie
Thema, irgendwie Zertifikate,
irgendwie Thema
Zertifikate, SSL,
irgendwie habt ihr Probleme, ja.
Ihr könntet jetzt zu den Leuten gehen,
die sich bei euch mit
Zertifikaten und Verschlüsselung und sowas beschäftigen
und in denen euer Problem
erklären und ihr hofft, dass die eine Antwort drauf haben
oder ihr googelt lieber eine Stunde
und findet die Antwort selbst.
In der Regel habe ich die Erfahrung gemacht,
wenn mir nicht sofort jemand einfällt,
den ich dazu fragen kann,
beziehungsweise wo ich mir sofort denke,
okay, der hat richtig Plan davon, der weiß das,
dann google ich lieber eine Stunde,
weil die meisten Sachen,
die meisten Sachen
arten immer aus,
wenn du Leute fragst.
Du fragst Leute so
nach dem Motto, ey,
mir fällt jetzt echt kein gutes Beispiel ein.
Machen wir ein anderes Beispiel.
Machen wir nicht Zertifikate.
Machen wir mal was ganz Simples.
Ihr wollt
farbige Konsolenausgabe
haben.
Farbige Konsolenausgabe wollt ihr haben.
Und ihr kommt damit nicht klar. Ihr habt das noch nicht
gemacht und
ihr habt keine Ahnung, was jetzt da für,
warum es nicht funktioniert.
Angenommen, ihr habt hier, keine Ahnung,
ihr habt das Komma an der Stelle vergessen
und ihr habt keine Ahnung, warum das nicht funktioniert.
Ihr kennt jetzt jemand,
der richtig krasser Bash-Hackerman
ist und, also
angenommen, ich würde das nicht hinkriegen und ich kenne jetzt jemand,
der übelst krass Bash-Hackerman ist,
von dem ich zig Skripte kenne, wo ich weiß,
der macht da Konsolenausgabe und aus irgendwelchen
Gründen checke ich es nicht, obwohl ich mir seine Skripte
angeguckt habe, dann würde ich den fragen. Dann würde ich sagen,
ey, äh, Kollege,
wie sieht's aus? Wie machst du immer deine
nice Farbausgabe? Und wenn
ich weiß, dass es jemand ist, der unkompliziert ist,
dass er sagt, ach ja, guck mal, du hast
das Semikolon vergessen, easy.
Dann frage ich den, da ist es in fünf
Minuten erledigt und sonst was.
So, ähm,
das Ding ist jetzt nur, dass es bei den meisten
Leuten ausartet. Die meisten Leute,
die würdest du fragen
und die sind sich dann selber nicht ganz
sicher, weil sie das nicht jeden Tag verwenden,
wollen aber nicht zugeben, dass es sich nicht ganz
sicher sind und erzählen dir dann erstmal
eine halbe Stunde von, ja,
also, als ich das letzte Mal eine Grafikausgabe
gemacht habe, da war das überhaupt nicht so gut,
weil dann ist das in Putty falsch dargestellt worden
und
warum willst du überhaupt eine grafische Ausgabe
machen? Ist es nicht meistens besser
zur Lesbarkeit, wenn es sich an der Konsole
orientiert? Und wenn es schon so anfängt, wenn ich
weiß, dass es solche Leute sind, dann sage ich, ey,
scheiß drauf, ich google jetzt erstmal
eine halbe Stunde.
Das klingt ein bisschen nach typischer
Forumsantwort, ja, aber das ist
ja nicht von ungefähr, dass Forumsantworten oftmals
so sind, dann google ich lieber eine halbe Stunde
und lerne
wahrscheinlich sogar noch mehr dabei,
weil ich dann in den Google-Antworten lerne,
okay, Backslash E ist nicht der einzige
Escape-Sequenz dafür und
ich sollte übrigens die Grafikausgabe
irgendwie noch terminieren
und sonst was. Deswegen
ehrlich gesagt, mit dem andere Leute
fragen, ist so ein ganz spezielles Thema,
was ich nur
in Fällen mache, wo
ich halt weiß, derjenige
das ist unkompliziert und
der weiß auch, wovon er spricht.
Ich meine, nur weil jemand, sagen wir mal, im
Team ist, was sich um
Zertifikate kümmert,
heißt das noch lange nicht, dass ich den fragen kann
und der mein Problem weiß.
Also ich habe die Erfahrung gemacht, dass man
in 80, 90 Prozent der Fälle,
wenn man nicht weiter weiß
und die Default-Antwort darauf
ist, ich frage jemand,
dass das in 80 bis 90 Prozent der Fälle
entweder nicht
zu einem sinnvollen Ergebnis führt,
also du
am Ende auch nicht schlauer bist,
oder es enorm lange dauert
und ich die Erfahrung gemacht
habe, dass man in der Regel mit
selbst suchen
meistens schneller zum Ziel
kommt. Es sei denn, es ist halt
wirklich was ganz spezielles, wo ich
halt gerade schon versucht habe zu
umschreiben.
Weiß nicht, je nachdem. Wenn ich Bock auf
Schwätzen habe, rufe ich die an, wenn ich keinen Bock auf Schwätzen
habe, rufe ich die nicht an.
Okay, dann.
Geheimnis 3, Geheimnis 3.
Er ist wohl der Wichtigste und mit dem habe ich die ganze Zeit
auch noch wirklich zu kämpfen und er ist gar nicht so einfach
umzusetzen. Aber während
meiner Zeit als Softwareentwickler konnte ich
das bei den erfolgreichsten Kollegen
feststellen, dass sie diese eine Eigenschaft
Ja auf, komm zum Punkt.
diese Eigenschaft hat sie wahrscheinlich an dem Punkt gekämpft, an dem
Tim, Tim, Tim, komm, komm
zum Punkt, please.
In der IT-Branche gibt es dauerhaft Änderungen. Es gibt immer wieder
neue Programmiersprachen, neue Tools,
neue Frameworks, neue Konzepte, such dir
... Moment, was meint
ihr, wie viele JavaScript-Frameworks wurden heute
schon neu auf GitHub
erstellt? Ich meine heute,
heute
europäische Zeit, also sagen wir mal von
in den letzten 12 Stunden?
... irgendwas aus. Es gibt immer was Neues
und diese neuen Sachen, die sind sowieso alle
immer besser als alles, was du davor
gelernt hast. Als ich beispielsweise vor
Herausforderungen stand, aus meinem gewohnten
Webentwicklungsumfeld herauszugehen und jetzt
in DevOps und Cloud-Technologien
einzusteigen. Das ist eine gute Idee gewesen.
Von ihm das zu machen. Habe ich mich anfangs
wirklich sehr, sehr unsicher und einfach
richtig schlecht gefühlt. Das ist normal.
Im Cloud-Umfeld ist es normal,
dass man überfordert ist, weil
je nachdem, in welchem
Umfeld man da ist,
weil dort täglich 50
neue Sachen spawnen,
gerade die Cloud-Anbieter
diesen Campbell auch nicht einheitlich benennen können,
Sachen umbenennen können.
Pakete. Letztens habe ich gesehen,
Google hat einfach eines ihrer Pakete
von Google Cloud SDK in Google
Cloud CLI umbenannt. Es gibt beide Pakete
noch. Und es gibt jetzt Pakete, es gibt
jetzt File-Konflikte, weshalb auch
immer.
Im Cloud-Umfeld ist
jeder planlos.
So kann man das auch sehen.
Welche Programmierer fühlen sich wohl damit,
sich unwohl zu fühlen?
Naja, das würde ich so nicht unbedingt unterschreiben.
Bei dem Punkt gebe ich ihm aber prinzipiell recht.
Also bei dem,
es ist teilweise schwierig,
sich von was
gewohntem,
gewohnte Aufgabengebiete
zu wechseln.
Ich finde das aber gar nicht so schlimm, solange es
was ist, was einen interessiert.
Wenn es etwas ist, was einen persönlich interessiert, dann ist das
alles halb so wild.
Ja, auch. Gut, gut.
Raspberry Pi 5 NVMe
2 SSD. Ja, nice, dass es
geht.
Das ist dieser Mikro,
ähm, nee, nicht Mikro, äh,
PCI Express,
den PCI Express
Steckplatz, den der Raspberry Pi jetzt hat.
Nice, dass es geht.
Praktisch sinnvoll, wahrscheinlich nur
in Grenzen, ja.
Gucken wir uns das nächste Mal an. Ihr habt ja gesagt,
es ist wirklich keine schlechte Doku.
Wollen wir uns das nächste Mal
angucken. Chat.
Gibt es noch was Spannendes diese
Woche, was ich noch nicht mitgekriegt habe,
wo wir unbedingt drüber sprechen müssen?
Weil ich mache mir jetzt gleich was
zu essen. Ach ja, die übliche Sache mit,
was gibt es heute zu essen? Wer weiß es?
Was? Ich habe vor ein paar
Jahren mein Defizit daheim nach und jetzt geht das
aber nicht mehr und ich fühle, was meinst du?
Du meinst, du hast viel daheim gelernt
an Themen und es geht
aus irgendwelchen Gründen jetzt nicht mehr oder was meinst du?
Also, geht das nicht mehr, weil du
keine, weil du keine Zeit hast, weil du
keinen Bock mehr hast, weil du zu beschäftigt bist
mit Familie drumherum?
Ist halt so.
Letztendlich, ihr kennt mich, ich habe es schon oft
gesagt, die meisten neuen
Technologien, die ich bisher
gelernt habe,
habe ich auch in meiner Freizeit gelernt
und konnte sie dann
im Nachhinein öfters mal
nicht bei allem, ja ich warte immer
noch auf den Zeitpunkt, wo ich meinen
Microcontroller, meine Microcontroller
Programmierskills mal auf der Arbeit
brauche.
So nach dem Motto, Max, wir haben schon immer
für unser Rack einen Microcontroller
mit Temperatursensor gebraucht.
Da warte ich ja noch drauf,
dass ich das da irgendwann mal brauche,
aber vieles von dem, wofür ich mich
ursprünglich erst privat beschäftigt habe,
habe ich auf der Arbeit auch
sinnig brauchen können.
Hätte ich nicht
angefangen, mich mit den unterschiedlichsten
Programmiersprachen, Frameworks,
Webanwendungen, Frontend, Backend, sonst
was zu beschäftigen, was ja eigentlich
nicht so die klassische
Physie-Sache ist,
die ich ja damals gelernt habe, wäre ich
wahrscheinlich nie im
DevOps-Umfeld gelandet, zu Zeiten,
als es das Wort DevOps noch gar nicht gab
und wäre jetzt
nicht dort gelandet, wo ich bin, also es ist
oftmals für was gut, ja.
Und es ist nie verschenkt,
ich glaube, das kann man auch nicht so oft
genug sagen, es ist nie verschenkt, wenn euch das
was gibt und wenn euch das gefällt.
Auch wenn ich
die, es geht ja nicht immer nur darum, dass
man damit irgendwie super erfolgreich
was im Beruf anfangen kann.
Mein Microcontroller-Programmierzeug,
auch was wir hier schon im Stream gemacht haben,
das Löten und das Basteln, das macht einfach
Bock. Es bringt daheim
was, ja, ich kann zum Beispiel meine
den,
den die Wasserzufuhr für
die Heizung im Keller, um
den Druck wieder ein bisschen zu erhöhen,
da muss man alle halbe Jahr
mal ein bisschen Wasser nachfüllen, kann ich
beispielsweise jetzt remote erledigen,
haben wir ja auch im Stream gebaut,
nämlich eine,
ein Ventilöffner,
haben wir das im,
das haben wir im Stream gebaut, gell?
Das war ein mega nices Ding.
Ventil.
Smartventil.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass es im Stream nicht funktioniert hat.
Ja.
Kann auch sein, dass ich es kaputt gemacht habe oder so.
Zumindest haben wir da
so ein,
so ein
Moment,
so ein Ding
habe ich mir bestellt,
was normalerweise
wieder, wie üblich, nur mit
China-Chinesen-Shit funktioniert,
und dann haben wir folgendes gemacht,
also das ist so gedacht, guck mal,
wenn ihr so ein Ventil habt,
dann setzt ihr das Ding da oben drauf,
und da ist ein Motor drin, das kann das dann
links und rechts bewegen,
und was wir im Stream gemacht haben ist,
wir haben einen ESP32,
was ist denn das für einer,
ein D1 Mini ist das wahrscheinlich,
es könnte sogar ein ESP
2866 sein, den ich hier habe, das ist glaube ich sogar
ein ESP 2866,
habe ich an die Steuerungspins
dran gelötet,
von diesem Motor,
oder nee,
nicht von dem Motor direkt,
einfach nur an die GPIOs dran gelötet,
die den Impuls für starten und stoppen gibt,
und jetzt kann ich
über WiFi mit dem
Controller das Ventil
auf und zu machen, ohne,
dass ich China-Chinesen-Hardware brauche,
was mache ich da gerade,
ich glaube,
das ging im Stream nicht, ich glaube, das war broken,
ich habe es irgendwie kaputt gemacht,
hat das denn am Ende funktioniert, was ich da gebaut habe, also,
mittlerweile funktioniert es,
weil ich habe es im Keller,
ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob die Iteration,
die im Stream,
die ich im Stream gebaut habe,
ob die funktioniert, alter,
hatte ich da noch dicke Hände, Mann,
ok, da war ich auch noch 18 Kilo, boah,
what the fuck,
da war ich auch noch 18 Kilo schwerer,
richtig Pepo-Fett-Fingers,
Alter,
richtig Chonker-Fingers,
so, hat es, hat es im Stream
funktioniert, ich bin mir unschlüssig,
ich glaube, es hat im Stream nicht funktioniert,
oder, ich glaube, das war ein Problem,
das hat nicht richtig funktioniert im Stream,
weil,
weil ich irgendwie
irgendwas, irgendwas kaputt gemacht habe,
äh, ne, es hat,
es hat nicht funktioniert, glaube,
jaja, also, wenn ich mit dem,
mit dem Multimeter anrücke,
da könnt ihr von ausgehen,
es ist irgendwas kaputt gewesen,
das kommt immer nur in Notfällen zum Einsatz,
es hat, es hat, glaube ich,
es hat, glaube ich, nie funktioniert im Stream,
oder hat es am Ende getan,
ne, ne, wenn ich dann nochmal
Löt-Action mache, es hat nicht funktioniert,
ich glaube, ich habe es dann,
ich glaube, ich habe es dann sein gelassen, ja,
es wird echt mal wieder Zeit
für eine Runde Bastel-Stream, so, oder?
Ich habe gerade aktuell
nichts zum Basteln, aber ich hätte mal wieder
Bock auf Löt-Bastel-Stells
im Stream.
Habe ich nicht noch ein paar China-Chinesen-
Steckdosen, die geflasht werden müssen,
die man nicht OTA
flashen kann, so irgendwas, das geht ja
immer.
Die Schredder-Bild.
Ja, mittlerweile funktioniert es, ich habe das schon
seit über einem Jahr, oder seit zwei Jahren
oder so, ich weiß nicht, wie lange der Stream her ist,
äh, im Keller, funktioniert wunderbar.
Was könnte man mal wieder basteln?
Mir fällt gerade echt nichts ein.
Wo ich
Elektronik-Stells
machen müsste.
Streamen gibt vor, was
du basteln könntest, der Streamer hat ja auch keine Ahnung.
Ja, aber jetzt, wie ich überhaupt noch
auf das Thema gekommen bin, das ist was,
das ist nice in daheim, das hat mir auf der Arbeit
nie was gebracht, ja, dass ich
Microcontroller basteln kann, aber
wichtig ist, es ist nie
verschenkt, wenn es einem Spaß macht und wenn da
wer weiß, wofür man das
nochmal brauchen kann.
Es gibt auch Sachen, die machen jetzt nicht unbedingt
so Spaß in
Form von
oh, nice, wie das
geklappt hat oder so, aber die sind trotzdem sinnvoll.
Und auf lange Sicht auch gut für
einen.
Ja, zum Beispiel sich ein bisschen
mehr bewegen, auch wenn es an manchen
Tagen nicht so viel Spaß macht.
Gießanlage für Blumen- und Fensteröffner.
Ne, habe ich
hier keinen Anwendungsfall für.
Wie kommt man am besten ins
Microcontroller-Game rein, spielerisch?
Nö, ich habe Heimautomatisierung-Sachen gebaut.
Also das Beste, was du machen kannst,
wenn du einsteigen willst, ist ein bisschen
Microcontroller-Programming.
Dann gehst du
zu Amazon, holst dir
ein ESP32, wobei Amazon
ist ganz schön teuer mittlerweile, ja.
Alter, what?
What?
Was wollen
die dafür haben mittlerweile?
Früher hast du für 15 Euro
drei Stück gekriegt, ein paar AliExpress, für
fünf Euro.
Sind die komplett des Wahnsinns
mittlerweile? Ja, drei Stück?
Das ist ja nix!
Ich habe noch 10er-Packs.
10er-Packs hier.
D1 Mini ESP32.
Warum ist der Scheiß so
teuer geworden? Boah, ey,
man, AliExpress sieht immer so krass nach Scam
aus. So, das ist doch hier
bestimmt ein bisschen günstiger geworden.
Ja, hier kommen wir den
preislichen Regionen schon etwas näher.
Ein Euro pro Stück und sowas.
ESP32
ist ein bisschen teurer. Ja, also
sowas in der Richtung.
Früher hatte doch jemand, wie heißt die?
ArtsDelivery. Hatte früher
auf Amazon immer welche.
Ey, das ist ja mal super
teuer geworden, Alter.
25 Euro für, ich meine, kann man machen.
Ich meine, kann man machen,
ja. Also, wenn du ein bisschen Microcontroller-Zeug
basteln willst,
natürlich kannst du dir auch ein Raspberry Pi
Pico oder sowas holen, der ist
sicherlich vielleicht ein bisschen
wenn du, wobei,
eigentlich gar nicht, ja. Also, ich finde,
das ist immer noch der beste Microcontroller
zum Basteln, so für
alle 0815 Sachen. So,
es ist aber, im Prinzip ist es fast egal,
ja. Hol dir irgendwie
drei Stück davon. Ich würde mir auch tatsächlich drei
Stück holen, weil man macht sowas auch mal relativ schnell
kaputt. Hol dir den ESP32,
die NodeMCUs sind ganz gut.
Also,
das hier ist ja der eigentliche ESP32
hier. Dieser, noch nicht mal das hier.
Der
Chip unter diesem Ding ist der ESP32.
Der Rest ist einfach ein Board,
was die ganzen Pins rausführt,
ja. Du hast mehrere Crown-Pins,
du hast ein 3- und 5-Volt-Pin,
5-Volt von USB, der Rest Ding läuft mit
3,3, dann hast du jede Menge
GPIO-Pins, I2C-Pins
und sonstige Dinger. Also,
ein ESP32 kann vieles. Zumindest,
worauf ich eigentlich raus will, wenn du dich
für irgendeine Microcontroller-Plattform entschieden
hast, dann
Platform.io, beste.
Damit kannst du zum Einstieg nichts
falsch machen. Das ist ein Visual Studio Code
Plugin, was dir
die meiste Arbeit erstmal abnimmt.
Du kannst im Prinzip
Visual Studio Code starten, Platform.io
installieren, dann musst du Visual Studio Code nochmal
neu starten, dann legst du ein Projekt an,
bei der Projekterstellung wählst du den Controller aus,
der richtet dir alles ein,
auch schon serielle Konsole,
du kannst flashen
einfach mit einem Job in Visual Studio Code,
du hast ein Projekt-Template, also
Platform.io macht es wirklich super simpel. Also,
wenn du dich da ein bisschen mit beschäftigen
willst, dann Platform.io. Und ich finde
den ESP32 einfach gut als
Einstiegsplattform. Ach, brauchen wir nicht.
Platform.io. Nehmen Platform.io.
Arduino IDE ist komplett outdated,
overrated, Platform.io, beste.
Kann sich auch Arduino in
Platform.io machen. Ja, Chatgear,
was meint ihr denn, was es heute gibt zu essen?
Es ist
nicht Nudeln mit Lachs, es ist
Nudeln mit Tomatensauce, korrekt.
Excellent!
Ich sehe, der Chatgear
weiß Bescheid.
Deine Frage wurde übersehen. Echt? Wo denn?
Wo ist das denn?
Ich suche mal nach dir. Yellow.
Du hast keine
Frage gestellt.
Da, guck. 1 von
1.
Du hast keine Frage gestellt in den
letzten 40 Minuten.
Oh doch, hast du, hast du. Die Frage
habe ich sogar gesehen. Die ist aber
älter als 40 Minuten.
Kannst du Domainregistrarer
empfehlen und ob ich auf etwas
achten sollte? Nee, kann ich nicht.
Ich bin bei
vier verschiedenen, fünf,
fünf verschiedenen
Domainregistrarern.
Ich bin einmal bei
Porkbun, die würde ich aber
gar nicht so
sehr empfehlen.
Mittlerweile haben sie eine gescheite
DNS-API für automatische Zertifikate
und sowas hatten sie lange Zeit nicht.
Porkbun, die sind halt einfach super billig.
Porkbun
habe ich, dann
habe ich Namecheap.
Nitrado habe ich
tatsächlich noch eine Domain. Fragt mich nicht, was mich
da gerettet hat.
Cloudflare.
Oh, das war's. Namesilo.
Namesilo habe ich
auch noch welche. Das ist der größte Schrottladen, ey.
Die haben mir
überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Du willst das,
wie kann ich mir sicher, ohne dass
jemand was mitbekommt,
Torrent private Linux-ISOs runterladen?
Natürlich. Ja, also für
Linux-ISOs, nur für Linux-ISOs
logischerweise,
ist Torrent vielleicht gar nicht die beste Idee.
Bei Hetzner hätte ich wahrscheinlich
auch ein paar Domains,
aber die kamen da gleich wieder mit
echtem Namen und Ausweisgedöns an,
da hatte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Ich halte von VPNs nix.
In diesem Fall kann man sich das
aber mal überlegen. Das ist glaube
ich eines der, also
sich Linux-ISOs über Torrent
runterladen und Geoblocking
zu umgehen, ist tatsächlich eines
der wenigen Sachen, wo ich sagen würde, hey, dafür ist
ein VPN sinnvoll.
Den ganzen restlichen Mist, den die euch so erzählen
mit ihr seid viel sicherer unterwegs
und was auch immer,
wir wehren Hacker für euch ab und ach
alles Blödsinn.
Leute, ich gehe jetzt
was essen.
Übelst Hunger.
Let's Encrypt machst du eh selbst.
Let's Encrypt geht auf allen Hosts,
auf allen Domainregistraten,
die eine DNS-API haben.
Let's Encrypt musst du eh selbst
machen, wenn du es richtig machen willst.
Also das Ding ist, oh, Moment, Moment, das muss ich jetzt mal kurz erklären.
Es gibt viele
Domainregistrate, die bieten automatische
SSL-Zertifikatsgenerierung
an. Das ist aber kompletter
Schwachsinn. Ihr generiert
doch nicht den Private Key
woanders,
um ihn euch dann runterzuladen. Das Ding heißt
nicht umsonst Private Key.
Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Let's Encrypt beim Anbieter generieren zu lassen.
Null. Was ihr machen müsst, ist
ein Domainregistrat euch aussuchen,
der eine DNS-API hat.
Oder
noch nicht mal. Wenn ihr nur
Public Services mit
Zertifikaten versorgen wollt, dann könnt ihr auch
HTTP-Challenge machen.
Na klar.
Wenn du dort auf
generiere Zertifikat für Domain klickst und es runterlässt,
natürlich generieren die das für dich. Die machen das, was
du machen würdest mit Let's Encrypt oder Certbot,
machen die dann für dich und du kannst runterladen.
Also, ihr braucht
ein Domainregistrat,
der DNS-API hat
und dann
benutzt ihr irgendeinen
Let's Encrypt
Client, sei es Certbot
oder ihr benutzt einen Reverse Proxy, der das eingebaut hat
und dann macht ihr
DNS-Authentifizierung.
Ja, Certbot ist schon ziemlich
Painschamp.
Aber dann macht ihr DNS-Zertifizierung
äh DNS-Zertifizierung
Zertifikatsgenerierung,
mit Let's Encrypt
über DNS-Challenge
und dann könnt ihr auch Zertifikate
generieren für Domains, die ihr nur rein
intern verwendet. Also ihr könnt euch an der Public Domain
registrieren, ja.
kappa.lul.hd.com
und dafür
könnt ihr euch Zertifikate generieren bei
rein internen Services mit DNS-Authentifizierung.
Also mit DNS-Challenge heißt
das ja. Ihr braucht einfach nur ein Domainregistrat,
der DNS-Challenge unterstützt.
DNS-Challenge finde ich ist
für sowas eigentlich immer das Praktischste.
Da gibt's auch, ja das
haben wir auch im Stream schon gemacht.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich simpel.
Wenn ihr wollt, können wir das nochmal machen.
In, in easy.
Wenn ihr wollt,
können wir das nochmal machen.
Ja.
Und
dann ist es egal, ob dein
Domainregistrat Let's Encrypt unterstützt
oder nicht.
Es gibt keine Let's Encrypt Unterstützung,
die ein Domainregistrat bieten muss.
Ein Domainregistrat macht zwei Sachen.
Der macht erstmal
eine Sache, aber meistens machen sie zwei
Sachen.
Der registriert die Domain für euch
und der stellt
ein DNS bereit. Streng genommen
sind das zwei unterschiedliche Paar Schuhe, aber
meistens ist das so.
So, und
wie das funktioniert, von der Theorie
her, mit Let's Encrypt
ist folgendes.
Es muss ja übrigens auch nicht Let's Encrypt sein,
deswegen, der Anbieter muss das nicht unterstützen.
Wichtig ist, dass sie eine DNS-API haben.
Das funktioniert dann folgendermaßen.
Ihr habt eine Raspberry Pi daheim,
die ein gültiges Zertifikat bekommen soll
für kappa-lul-hd.com.
Ihr registriert euch
kappa-lul-hd.com
bei einem x-beliebigen
Domainregistrat und dann nehmt ihr
einen Let's Encrypt Client, zum Beispiel
Certbot. Es gibt noch jede Menge andere.
Ihr könnt auch einen Proxy
nehmen, der das schon eingebaut ist. Egal, nehmen wir mal
Certbot. Nehmen wir
Let's Encrypt Client xy. Das ist vollkommen
egal, welcher. Dadurch, dass ihr intern
seid, könnt ihr nicht die normale
http-Challenge machen.
Die normale http-Challenge bei
Let's Encrypt sieht folgendermaßen aus.
Ihr habt einen Linux-Server
oder ihr habt einen Server
und ihr stellt bei eurem
Domainregistrat ein.
Hinter www.kappa-lul-hd.com
ist halt die
Public IP von eurem Server.
Darauf startet ihr
einen Webserver.
Der Webserver fragt ein Zertifikat bei Let's Encrypt an.
Let's Encrypt
macht eine DNS-Auflösung
zu
der IP,
wo der Webserver von euch steht.
Und
Let's Encrypt
erwartet, dass dort auf diesem Webserver
eine Datei liegt mit einem
Secret, was sich der Client und
Let's Encrypt im Step davor
ausgemacht haben.
Und wenn die Datei mit diesem
Secret auf dem Webserver liegt, dann beweist
das für Let's Encrypt, dass ihr Eigentümer der
Domain seid.
Weil ansonsten würde die Domain nicht
auf euch auflösen und es würde nicht das vorher
ausgemachte Secret da liegen und gut ist.
Das funktioniert aber nur bei Public
Server. Wenn ihr jetzt einen
internen Service habt, so einen
Raspberry Pi, der aber eure
registrierte Domain benutzt, dann müsst ihr
DNS-Challenge machen. DNS-Challenge
funktioniert so. Ihr benutzt einen
Let's Encrypt Client, der geht zu
Let's Encrypt und sagt, ich hätte gern
für kappa-lul-hd.com
ein Zertifikat.
Dann machen die eine gemeinsame geheime
geheimes Passwort nennen wir es mal,
ein geheimes Secret miteinander aus.
Und dann
muss der DNS-Server
für diese
Domain, für das ihr das
Zertifikat ausstellen wollt,
muss einen TXT-Record anbieten
mit dem vorher ausgemachten Secret.
Und meistens
funktioniert das so, dass
der Let's Encrypt Client
eben verschiedene
Register unterstützt,
sei es jetzt Cloudflare oder
Namecheap oder was auch immer, dass
die verschiedenen Domain-Registrare unterstützen
und über die DNS-API
von diesen Domain-Registraren
dann dieses
TXT-Record mit dem
Secret hinterlegt. Das ist nicht
zwingend notwendig, ihr könnt das auch von
Hand machen. Also es gibt
auch so einen Manual-Mode,
dann könnt ihr quasi selbst in das Web-Interface
gehen, das Secret
hinterlegen und
dann sagen, jawohl, das Secret ist da und
Let's Encrypt guckt, ist das Secret das, was ausgemacht
wurde und dann gibt es euch ein Zertifikat.
So, das ist eigentlich so der Ablauf von
DNS-Challenge. Das Dumme ist nur, wenn
es nicht automatisch über die API geht,
von eurem
Domain-Registrar oder besser gesagt
von dem, wo ihr
auch immer euren DNS-Server laufen habt,
dann ist
es schwierig mit automatischer Erneuerung
und Let's Encrypt stellt ja nur Zertifikate
aus, die maximal drei Monate, gell?
Früher waren bis zu einem halben Jahr, ich
glaube, mittlerweile nur noch drei Monate
gültig sind. Das heißt, ihr müsst früher
oder später automatisch das Zertifikat
erneuern und wenn das nicht automatisch
geht und immer nur mit einem manuellen Step, ist
doof.
Deswegen.
Ihr braucht eine DNS-API, aber das kann mittlerweile
so gut wie jeder Domain-Registrar.
Explizit Let's Encrypt
unterstützen müssen die nicht und
ich würde auch ganz dringend davon abraten,
Zertifikate dort generieren zu lassen
und sie mir anschließend runterzuladen.
Einfach selbst Let's Encrypt machen, das ist
easy mittlerweile, das kriegt jeder hin.
Wir können es, wenn ihr wollt, das auch das nächste Mal
nochmal im Stream machen. Da habe ich sogar
ein Thema, was ich aus dem Ärmel schütteln kann
und schnell gemacht ist.
Für Technik-Course streamen
und dann ist gut.
So, ich geh jetzt wirklich was essen, Leute.
Wir sehen uns. Vielleicht
bin ich nachher noch mit den letzten
Zügen des PvP-Events
unterwegs, hier auf
Twitch. Das interessiert natürlich dann
nicht so viele Leute, aber die einen oder anderen gucken ja trotzdem
immer ganz gerne oldschool
beim OKreisetcoin. Dann aber mit Delay
muss ich schon so 3 Minuten
mal 3 Minuten Streamdelay machen.
Weil
PvP
mit Streamsniping
war ja nicht so geil.
Muss ich mal nachher gucken. Aber das dann erst
heute Nachmittag, wenn überhaupt.
Ich hätte aber
mal wieder Bock drauf. Aber mit Delay, ich stream
so ungern mit Delay.
Aber es geht nicht anders.
Jetzt mit Delay zu streamen.
Na gut.
Moin.
Ich bin jetzt aber auch weg.
Ich geh jetzt was futtern. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.